(whoosh)
(pops)
- [Connor] Ooh!
- Wait, how do you do that?
(whoosh)
(farts)
- Yeah, you wish you knew
the powers of my (farts).
(laughs)
Okay, hold on.
(pops)
- Oh, it's bass.
(calm music)
- [Connor] Where's my lid?
- [Ashley] You need the lid?
- Of course I need to lid,
it's a collection item.
- Whoa!
(loopy tune)
- It needs the lid.
- Why do you have a mug
with no liquid in it?
- [Ashley] Yeah.
- Yeah, why are you asking for a lid?
- Well, why are you asking for a lid
if you're not gonna
drink coffee out of it?
- [Ashley] Do you need coffee?
- I need this air to be nice and cool.
- I do actually, but also you know,
I think of this mug as a collectors piece,
as should the viewers who bought it,
and it should always have the lid on it.
- Yeah, but there's...
- Yeah, you don't have like Santa Claus
without the red suit on,
you know what I mean?
Like you don't have the Trash
Taste mug without the lid.
- Yeah, but you just gotta,
you have like a coffee cup right there.
And you have like a
mug that's just unused.
- Here, get this outta here,
why is there a lid on the floor?
- Did you drink the coffee not
out of the Trash Taste mug?
- [Connor] No.
- [Navi] This dude has been
doing that for a lot of things.
- I don't like transferring
liquids from like...
- Fake Trash Taste fan.
- I also want my Trash Taste mug.
- I don't like transferring
liquids (laughs).
- I like the mug.
Look at this man's mug!
Look at this shit!
How did you get this shit all on there?
- Dude, I've been drinking out of it.
- This doesn't look like drinking.
- This is a used mug.
- Used?
You fucking slobbered all over it,
half the coffees on the fucking mug.
- Have you seen this man drink?
- Yeah, he (licks).
- He's like, he doesn't
know where his mouth is.
- Garnt is like a person
who used to be a dog
in another life, but
just never forgot how to.
- He drinks like his mouth.
- Are you kidding me,
I would love to be a dog in my next life,
or this current life.
Dogs have the easiest
fucking lives in existence.
Dogs and cats.
You just do nothing all day.
- They piss, shit and
unconditionally love,
that's all they do.
(laughs)
- Right?
- That's what a dog is.
- I watched a...
- Have we done our intro yet?
- No, we haven't.
- Hi, this is the intro, Joey's the host.
- Yes, hello Sonic fans, I'm
Joey, welcome to Trash Taste.
I'm with Garnt and Connor.
- Episode 69, this deserves more.
- Hey!
- More of an intro than that.
- I texted Felix earlier when we found out
that this was episode 69,
'cause a little backstory.
So, you know, Felix, who, PewDiePie,
who we've been trying to get on the show,
can't come to Japan 'cause you know,
obviously 'cause of the world situation.
So, well we hoped that
by episode 69, hopefully,
he would have been able to come.
Obviously he couldn't.
So I texted him and said, I'm sorry, man.
- Didn't he specifically
say reserve episode 69?
- Yeah, he was like, Joey,
if I'm not on episode 69,
I am just not coming on.
- 'Cause I remember you telling me that
in like episode two or three or something
just when Trash Taste
started and I'm just like,
are we even gonna be
around for episode 69?
Are we even gonna have
an audience by then?
- Yeah, I was like, wow, Felix,
you're very positive thinker to be like,
thinking 65 episodes ahead.
- I was just like, I couldn't
even envision episode 69
'cause I was just like, I'll
be happy if we can last a year.
- Yeah.
- Break even with the podcast.
- It's weird to think that
we're probably gonna reach
a 100 episodes.
- That's scary isn't it?
- I was gonna be like,
which episode Trash Taste did this in?
Oh, it's 179, actually.
- Yeah, right?
- That's weird to think
that that could be a thing.
- Scary.
- 'Cause when I see Joe Rogan,
it's like episode 800 or
something, I'm like fuck!
- But doesn't he record
three episodes a week
or something like that?
- It's once every two days.
- [Connor] Holy, and
they're four hours long.
- The man loves to talk, man.
- Holy fuck.
I thought I run out of
topics to talk about.
- Yeah, right?
- Oh my God.
- You know, just sitting
through one episode of Joe Rogan
really makes me appreciate
just how much shit, A, he knows
and B, how good he is at
stretching out a single topic.
No, but seriously, because
after 800-something episodes,
four hours at a time, you
have to learn to like...
- Well, I feel like when you're very,
you do talk about current topics
and you very much get
involved with politics.
- But as well, even if
it's not current topics,
he's very good at kind
of really extensively
going into a topic to the point where
a topic that can last maybe, what,
10 minutes on Trash Taste,
can last up to an hour
on the Joe Rogan show.
- He really stretching
out that 15 minute mark.
- He's really thinning
out his call center.
I'm just kidding (laughs).
- How many ads can we fit in here?
No, I mean, when you talk about politics,
they suddenly turn what could
be two-minute conversations
into 10 hours.
- That is true.
Maybe we should do that.
- Are you fucking kidding me?
- I don't wanna do that.
- Are you kidding me?
I think the reason people
come to watch Trash Taste
is to escape political nonsense.
- I come to Trash Taste
to escape a lot of political nonsense.
I'm just like, I just
wanna talk with the boys.
- Everyone who talks about
it, I feel like it's not,
I'd feel like no one is
educated enough about it.
And so, when everyone talks about it,
I don't know which level of education
you need in this topic.
But I feel that no one has enough
'cause everyone seems to always
have some fucking argument
that I'm like, what the fuck is going on?
- The problem with a lot
of political topics is...
- Ah, thank you man, is
that the Trash Taste mug?
- Are you gonna drink coffee out of it?
- You bet your ass I am.
- Yeah, I'll take the lid
as well, give me the lids.
- No, 'cause I completely agree.
'Cause a lot of the times
there are some topics
where you just genuinely don't
know which side to listen to
'cause both sides are just
at each other's throat.
And I'm just like, I don't feel like.
- Every time someone brings up
some kind of political
conversation because I,
A, just don't really care
about politics in general
and B, I'm again, not
knowledgeable about it anyway.
- You don't care about
politics in general?
- No.
- That's taking a stance
in itself, Joey.
- Yeah, wow, right.
- See that's privilege,
to be able to not care.
- But like everything, it
doesn't matter what it is.
It could be like the most far left thing,
it could be the most far right thing.
And my only two answers
is just, "Oh, that sucks".
Or, "Oh, that's good", I guess.
- I keep up with it,
but I do also really
despise the era we're in
where it's all.
- Everything is political?
- Well, yeah.
- No, it's not that
everything's political,
it's everyone has to be involved in it,
and has to be educated in it.
- Everyone needs an opinion about it.
- I feel like the main players
are all just YouTubers,
and I'm like, I don't trust YouTubers.
I'm a YouTuber, I don't
trust other YouTubers.
- I don't trust myself.
(laughs)
Don't trust yourself.
- I know what we're like.
And I know for a fact that
these people cannot be doing
that good of a job.
And when I listen to them,
I'm like, okay, this is fine.
You know, to me, it's also
been highly monetized now.
I feel like money has become
such a big player in it
that I don't wanna watch any
of these people on YouTube
telling me about why they believe X person
has no rights or whatever.
'Cause it's like, you
got a horse in this race
to talk about it.
You gotta get people
angry and upset about it
so you can get dollars.
- There's something in it for you.
- Which is why I also hate it a lot
and I also just don't really
like talking about it online
'cause it's a shitshow.
And also, everyone has their own opinions.
- It is a shitshow and I
just feel like some things
are just better discussed
in private with the person,
because there's only so much you can say
in 140 characters on Twitter.
And that's unfortunately
where a lot of these
opinions are being spread
and it's easy to, one,
misrepresent your own ideas
and two, other people to
misrepresent your ideas.
- And might take it out of context.
- It just seems like a
lose-lose situation for me,
and two, I don't know why it's just so bad
or why more people just don't agree
that sometimes you just
aren't educated enough
or you just don't know
enough about a topic
to just have an opinion on it.
- Yeah, and you say that and,
I feel like there's so many things now
where we just have so much
information on topics,
where, yeah okay, maybe someone can,
two parties can present the
complete opposite argument,
but there's enough information
where they can kind of
both make that point
because they have enough points
that work with one person
and enough points that
work with the other.
It's like, okay, well I can
get educated on all of it.
And then when you do try and
educate yourself on everything
in a certain situation, you just realize,
I just hate all of this.
Everything is just
fucked and nothing works.
- Pretty much.
- There's no right answer.
- What do I do?
- Yeah, I've gotten to
that point a lot of times
where it's just like, how
do I fix this problem?
I have absolutely no fucking clue.
I don't even know where to start.
The more I read, the
more depressed I feel.
- And the rest of the
world was like, first time?
No one knows the answer and
that's why we're arguing.
- It's like the whole thing with the,
you should reduce your energy usage
to help combat global warming.
And then it's just the whole thing of,
but then also like BP is like spilling
the entire oil supply to the ocean.
And it's like, well, I feel
like I'm not really the problem.
I feel like it's not really me,
but then you see that and people get angry
and then it's like, well,
but then you're like,
well change it, we should
vote against these companies.
But that's been proven that doesn't,
it doesn't really fucking
work half the time.
'Cause clearly someone makes a new rule
that they can go and harvest..
- The whole game is busted.
So no matter how many
times you change the rules,
it's just not gonna
turn out to be the game
that you wanna play.
- It sucks!
It all fucking sucks.
- It does, and that's why
we don't talk about it
on Trash Taste.
- It always goes to the negative for me,
which is why I'm just like,
I'm on Trash Taste with the boys,
I just wanna shut off
the internet for a while.
- I wanna talk about how I
wanna be reincarnated as a dog.
- It's okay to stop caring, you know,
there's just too much,
there's way too much.
- 'Cause right now we're just
so overloaded with information
and things to care about.
- I literally gotta shit
myself if somebody sneeze
within two feet of me,
and now I gotta worry
about what's going on?
You know, in multiple countries now.
I'm a UK, I live in Japan,
gotta keep up with dual politics?
- That's the biggest thing
that's changed, right?
Because before, everyone
only needed to care
about what was around them.
And now being people on the internet,
I have to care about
everything going on globally.
And it gets to the point
where there are so many
different cultures,
so many different points of view,
so many different like experiences
that each individual has had,
that sometimes it's
impossible for a lot of people
to get the same viewpoint on things.
Because even for us who've
lived in multiple countries
and have had experience
with multiple cultures.
You can say we're cultured ourselves.
(laughs)
Saying this in like the
pure, unironic sense,
because you get this
sense whenever I go home,
or whenever I hear about
any of us going home
and you see people who have
stayed in their home towns
not left their home towns
and they have the exact same viewpoint
that they got raised on, right?
And coming from the place,
you kind of understand how
they got that viewpoint
even though you don't agree with it.
You know what I mean?
But you also understand that
they don't have anything
to really change their viewpoint in there
because they've never
experienced anything else.
- There's no new information that comes in
to stimulate that change
in thought process.
So forever they just think,
well this is correct,
because this is what
it was like around me.
I don't know about anything else
that's happening in the world,
so this is just how I'm
going to see the world.
But then, for instance, I
remember when I first came back
to Australia after I was living here
and I would go see my
friends and stuff like that
who have been there the entire time.
I dunno, things that I
remember I used to be able
to very heavily relate with
and kind of almost agree upon,
I found myself to be like,
oh, is this how I felt?
Is this really what my
thought process was like?
And it's so weird because
like that didn't even happen
in that much of a large space of time.
Like that only maybe happened
in two years or something,
of just living here.
And I think definitely doing
YouTube and stuff like that
has got me to interact
with so many more different
nationalities and cultures
and stuff like that.
Doing this job, you're almost
forced to be up-to-date
with everything that's
happening in the world
because you have people all over the world
who are viewing you, right?
So I have this weird pressure of being,
I don't want this one
person from this one country
coming into my streams
or whatever and being,
do you know what's happening
in my country right now?
And me going, no, I don't.
- Yeah, you get that,
like what do you think
about the current gentrification
of Southeast Macau,
and you're like, what the fuck?
How the fuck would I know that.
- Wat is Macau?
(laughs)
- You get that a lot.
You surely can't expect me
to have a horse in this race,
please, come on.
- I'm just kidding people from
Macau, I know what Macau is.
But that's the thing,
you're almost pressured
to be up to date on that kind of stuff,
because you don't wanna
leave any of your viewers out
and stuff like that.
And so, that causes you to just,
it absorbs so much
information about the world
that when I go back to my
hometown and I meet people
who aren't up to date
on that kind of stuff
who have completely different
viewpoints of the world,
because the amount of information
that they absorb about the
world is on a different level.
It's, I dunno, it's a bit of a whiplash.
I'd be like, ooh, I can't believe
I used to think like that.
That's kinda weird.
- I don't even know my I'm blood type,
so I don't even expect people
to learn about the outside.
How do people expect me
to keep up with weird news
in some country I've never heard of.
I think you should be the one
to know your own blood type.
- I'm sure I should, I have
a blood disease as well.
(laughs)
- I have a blood disease,
I don't know what my blood type is though.
- I don't know.
- It's pretty irresponsible.
You also had to do a blood test here,
and you were shown your blood type.
Having said that, I don't
know my blood type either,
I got the same...
- What!
- I'm just as monkey-brained
as him apparently.
- I know it's in the alphabet.
Like it's one of them.
- It's in the alphabet!
- It's one of the four.
- What is your blood type?
Sigma.
(laughs)
- Delta, alpha, sigma.
- Alpha, sigma.
- I'm like, decaf?
I don't know.
(laughs)
I don't know, and I do, like you said,
you do try to educate
yourself on some things,
but there's just so, you know,
you can't be expected to
keep up with so many things.
- Like here's a question then,
do you feel like there's a big difference
between explaining to
someone your perspective
and actually having the
person really experience it
and empathize with you?
'Cause I feel like those
are two different things.
- Yeah, I can sit here,
I could go back to Wales
and explain Japanese culture all day
and they just won't understand it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Why would you do that?
Why would you bow at
every single, every word?
Why would you say, excuse
me, every 10 seconds.
- To me, it's kind of very similar to,
let's say learning a language,
where you can explain a language,
you can explain grammar
structures and you can explain
how the writing system and stuff works.
But there's a difference
between understanding
how a language works and
actually just absorbing it
and really getting a feel
for the language yourself.
I know there's a word for it,
acquisition, language acquisition,
versus just learning how it
works on a logical sense.
And I feel the exact same way
when it comes to cultures and perspective
where there's been so many times
where someone has told
me about a perspective
and you're logically like,
"Yeah, I agree with that".
You know, they could be
making the most sense,
but then you kind of
maybe move to the country
that they're living in
or you go travel there
or you meet more people
from that same culture.
And you're like, oh,
I think I actually get
what you're talking about now, you know?
- Yeah, I think it's like
how when you're growing up
and you hear about other
countries and you think,
oh, it's that funny little
thing that country does.
I know they would probably
do this about Japan a lot,
they would just show
with things like Sumo,
and they'd be like, isn't that so strange.
- These big men in diapers
pushing each other around.
- It's one of those things, aint it?
But I think that when you get
to experience more cultures,
your mindset on when you see
stuff like that changes a lot.
You go from thinking,
oh, that funny thing,
that weird, strange thing, to thinking
I'm sure there's a story behind it.
I'm sure there's a history,
there's a culture behind it.
- I definitely felt that,
especially after I started dating Aki
and you know, through YouTube
meeting a lot of Americans,
because in Australia, the image of America
is not that glamorous
or positive in any way.
I'm just saying it's straight up.
- I don't think the image
of Americans in America.
I love that the Americans
are often the first people
to bash their own country.
- Right, exactly.
- I love you, America.
- It depends on where they're from.
- Yeah, it depends.
But after actually going to America
and talking to Americans
and stuff like that,
that completely flipped it
over and I realized, oh,
the problem was just
kind of my environment
that was pushing that agenda
and the media that I consumed
that was kind of pushing
this sort of negative agenda
about American culture
and stuff like that.
But then when you actually
go and you live it out,
you see it firsthand and
you see everything else
that they don't show and you're like,
oh, actually it's not as insane or wacky
as the TV shows or the shit
my friends were talking about,
make it out to be, you know?
- Yeah, but I remember when I
first started dating Sydney.
I remember when we first met
and first started dating,
I remember early on,
'cause she mentioned
this to me the other day.
I asked her, so out of curiosity,
what do you actually think about America?
And she was like, oh,
greatest country in the world.
And I remember.
- Was she dead-ass when she said it?
- Imagine, she came from a
small town in the Midwest
- Oh when you first started dating?
- Yeah, when I first started
dating her five, six years ago,
shit, seven years ago now actually.
It was a long time ago and I remember
that was the first time
she had basically traveled
out of America, and she
came from a very small town
in the Midwest and got
raised with the values
that you would expect a
small town to get raised in.
I remember she said, oh yeah,
America is the greatest country
in the world, obviously.
And I remember, apparently she said,
I was just like, "Hmm".
(laughs)
Like that.
- And she said to me at the time,
she got like genuinely offended, right?
She straight up, she got
genuinely angry at me
at the time for doing that.
She was like, what'd you mean, why?
Why did you make that sound?
She said to me, and I was like,
so what constitutes the greatest country?
And why is America the greatest country?
And she was like, oh, land
of the free, isn't it?
We got freedom.
- I was about to say.
And second, I'm like, "Hmm".
- I was about to say,
if she's about to drop the freedom bomb,
I don't know what I can say to that.
- No, because to me at the time,
it was just living up to
the stereotypical patriotic American,
'cause America is a
good country, you know?
But my issue is, the more I
travel, the more I'm just like,
is there a greatest country in the world?
And there's no way you can define
the greatest country in the world.
- Otherwise everyone will be living there.
- Yeah, exactly.
And to me, patriotism,
as a British person,
is just so weird.
Like, you see it, I see
American patriotism where,
you know, not saying
every American like this,
but especially some of
the Americans I've met
who were raised in small towns,
especially when I go back
to Sydney's hometown,
it's just, you see this
culture that's been,
and this idea that's just been propagated
through the small town,
and there's not really
been any other perspective
to really change that perspective.
They probably believe, by their belief,
they probably believe that America
is the greatest country in the world
and there is no other thing
that can challenge that.
And it's just, I can't
blame them for that.
- No of course not.
- And I'm not even saying
America isn't the greatest
country in the world.
I'm just saying that because their belief
has been permeated so deeply
that there's been nothing
to really break that mold for them.
And it took years for Sydney
to really kinda change her perspective.
It didn't take like just
one trip to England.
It took years for her traveling
to living with me in England
and living with me in Thailand
and living with me in Japan,
for her to like really open
up her perspective to be like,
you know what, maybe there are
some other good places
in the world as well.
You know, maybe some other
places do things as good.
And now she has recently
just gone back to America
to visit her family and she's like,
wow, I really don't fit there anymore.
- Really?
- Yeah, it felt weird,
'cause she told me that
she just didn't feel
as settled as she used to be.
- Mhmm.
- Ah, I get that too.
- She feels like an outsider almost.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I definitely got that
when I was back in Wales last time.
I don't know, I love my
hometown and I love my friends,
but you definitely feel like
'cause you've been doing
so many things and exploring
so many different cultures,
you definitely feel like,
God, I must sound like that
weird fucking gap student
who come back, like, I've
traveled the world now,
I'm better than all of you.
- 'Cause I really don't
wanna sound like that.
- Yeah, no, but it does
open your perspective a lot
and you do think, oh shit,
it really just made you look
at stuff in your tiny
town a lot differently.
And you know, how homogenous it is.
- The tiny town just feels
so much more tinier, weirdly.
And you know, again, I don't blame Sydney
or anyone from the small
towns who think that way,
because again, I feel,
especially in America,
it really is just kind of enclosed
when it comes to the
information that you can get
about the rest of the world.
It still blows my mind that
in America, for example,
24-hour news channels are a
thing, but it's not world news,
it's American news for 24-hours.
And I'm like, what?
It's just insane to think,
for one, there's so much
news happening in America
that you can just
constantly run news stories.
But also, there's just so little access
or ease of access to
information outside of America.
- Same in the UK though, really.
We get like, we get
trickled down to America.
We don't really get to see
a lot of inside America.
A lot of British people don't
really know many of the states
outside the very famous ones.
- Oh, I'm sure it's the same
in Australia as well, though.
- Stuff like that.
And we have very rudimentary knowledge
of outside of Europe, really.
- But do you guys have
world news on your TV?
- Yeah, we do, we do.
- But like world news is just mostly,
it's mostly the Middle East conflict.
- Yeah, stuff that we fucked up, really.
Stuff that we had a hand in.
- Yeah, fair enough.
(laughs)
- It's rare that we hear
anything about Japan
or Asia in general, unless
something massive has happened.
- Well, 'cause of the Olympics normally.
Because BBC scarcely reports on Japan.
I have the BBC app and
I set the Japan section,
they don't do an article
every three days on Japan.
And it would be very,
it'd probably be quite high
profile stuff in Japan.
Or very wacky, whoa!
They open up a new store with M&M's,
whoa!
- Whoa!
- Also, I do think as well,
the fact that a lot of people think,
one of the reasons why people
already think America is terrible is,
in the UK and also in
Japan I feel this as well.
A lot of this bad stuff and
injustices, if you will,
in the UK and I think Japan as well,
probably don't get as much
spotlight as they do in America.
And also everything is
fucking filmed in America.
- [Joey] True.
- Literally everything is on camera.
- True, true, true.
- So I feel like it's way
easier to catch the stuff
that makes your country
look fucking insane.
- Yeah.
- When there's cameras
all the fucking time,
capturing everything.
I feel like one of the main reasons
why we see so many insane
stuff for America looks good
and you hear all these horrible injustices
that have been done is 'cause
there's just so much video
and there's so much attention
brought to it by the media.
- I mean, it's also as well the fact that
just simply the population
difference is one thing as well.
But it's also, again,
it's just that whole cultural mentality
or I guess group mentality of,
it's me versus the world, you know?
'Cause it's very much an
individualistic society
where it's like, I'm the center...
- We have that in the UK
as well to some extent.
- I think the UK way more.
I think that's definitely
one of the biggest difference
between East and West that I've felt
living in both different places.
- Yeah, and whereas in Japan it's like,
oh, I don't wanna stick out too much
'cause otherwise the camera
might get stuck on me.
- But it's hard right?
'Cause on one hand you get society
where everyone's comfortable
nobody oversteps their boundaries,
but everyone's fucking miserable.
- Exactly.
- You can't have this utopian ideal Japan
without also having a depressed society
where no one can have fun.
- And I feel that's like problem right now
is that regardless of if you're
an individualistic society
versus a collective society,
there's still shit that happens right?
- Yeah, like the stuff I love about the UK
is also, I'm near certain,
the stuff that I love,
or is also the reason why
we have a lot of the stuff
I don't like about the UK.
- Yeah, exactly.
I mean, same thing with Japan.
- You don't get the good
things and not the bad things.
- No, there's no perfect country.
- There's no perfect
country and I don't think
there's a perfect system.
- Denmark's just like, hello.
Allow me to.
- Switzerland is like.
- I read an article that was like,
people who live in
Denmark that are unhappy
are extremely unhappy because
they're supposed to be
the happiest country on Earth.
So the people who get sad there
or their life isn't
going the way they want,
they feel more depressed
because they're supposed to be.
- Because everyone around them is happy.
- You're supposed to be in
the happiest place on Earth.
You can't fucking win.
No matter what goes wrong, you can't win.
But I think, obviously,
that also depends on
if you can afford to be
healthy and all that stuff.
So that all changes, obviously.
Being healthy is pretty good.
This video is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- Did you ever read the
fine print that appears
when you stop browsing in Incognito mode?
- No, I don't think I did.
- Well, it says that your activity
might still be visible to your employer,
your school or your
internet service provider.
How could they even call it Incognito!
(cries)
It's okay, Connor, you can stop crying.
- Okay?
- Because to really stop people
from seeing the sites you visit,
you need to do what I do, get ExpressVPN.
- Holy shit, everything's fixed.
(laughs)
- Think about all the
times you've used wifi
at a coffee shop, a hotel
or even your parents' house.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- Without ExpressVPN, every site you visit
could be logged by the
admin of that network.
And that's still true even
if you use Incognito mode.
- What's more, I just found out
that your home internet provider
can also record your browsing data.
- Shee!
- And in the U.S. they're legally allowed
to sell that data to advertisers?
- Shee!
- And ExpressVPN is the app that encrypts
all of your network data and
reroutes it through a network
of secure service so that
your private online activity
stays that, just that, priva-
- Ceee!
(laughs)
- Holy shit!
Oh my God ExpressVPN also
works on all of your devices.
- [Joey] Hell, yeah.
- The app literally has one button,
you tap to connect to it
and your browsing activity
is secured from prying eyes.
So stop letting strangers
invade your online privacy,
protect yourself at
expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
Use our link and expressvpn.com/trashtaste
to get three extra free months, free.
That's expressvpna.com/trashtaste,
to learn more.
- I can't handle!
- Back to the episode.
- Are you guys patriotic?
- Uh, no.
Only in like sport, I guess.
- To Wales, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Pretty much the most patriotic
I get is towards sports.
- But you have to, okay,
so I think Wales' patriotic
and being in the UK is a very different.
- How many times, how often do you get
to be patriotic about Wales?
- Anytime England fucks up.
(laughs)
- Basically right.
- That's the truth.
- You're just like, I'm not part of that.
- So that's what I'm saying, it's not.
Patriotism in Wales is not like
the rest of the world patriotism
where it's like, go us!
It's just fuck England.
- I feel like that's just
- That's literally all it is.
- Wales, Scotland and Irish?
Like Northern Irish patriotism.
- Right, that's why, I
feel like UK patriotism
is a completely different brand to other.
'Cause we get very proud
of Welsh people, obviously.
But we get the most proud when it is
to the detriment of England.
So when people are like, oh,
you're English though, right?
It's like, no, I'm not even, I have no.
There is absolutely nothing
about me that is English.
I'm British and Welsh, but not English.
So a lot of people always like,
well, that's English, right?
No, no, no, no, I despise.
But I despise it in a very fun way.
It's very much like.
- Tongue in cheek.
- There's a lot of fun stories.
- It's a bit of banter, right?
- Yeah, yeah, have you
watched "Archer", the TV show?
- A little bits of it, yeah.
- Yeah, there's a really weird thing
that just completely caught me off guard.
So they did an episode
about a very famous Welsh
event that happened.
And it was very weird that "Archer",
an American comedy TV show did this.
So, there's a thing called
a Tryweryn in Wales.
And it's a small town
that no longer exists
because Liverpool, which
is a city in England,
wanted a reservoir.
So their solution to getting a reservoir
was to just flood this town
so they could get water.
- Holy shit.
- I shit you not.
So they had to evacuate,
they literally just made people just move.
- Wow, okay.
- And Welsh people weren't allowed to vote
on whether this was.
- So they had no say.
- They had no say.
So they just flooded this town,
called Tryweryn and turned
it into a reservoir.
Turned out, they didn't
even need it in the end.
And they killed four people as well
because some people refuse to leave.
- Holy shit.
- So they flooded it.
It's legit, you can go there.
It's depressing as fuck because
they're just like buildings
underneath this reservoir.
And there's a bunch, around
the area is a ton of like,
remember Tryweryn and stuff like that.
And it's seen as one of
the most like injustices
that were done to Wales.
- Well, yeah, that's pretty shitty.
- It was fairly recent as well.
- How recent we're talking?
- Think '60s, can you Google it?
It's like '60s, '80s,
around that time, I think.
Just Tryweryn, T-R-Y-W-E-N
- I pretty sure that's just the
plot to Higarashi, isn't it?
Didn't Higarashi get to build a dam
and then there were
protests to stop the people
from getting out?
- It just acts as a reservoir
so English people could drink water
and then they didn't even use it.
(laughs)
It's like, what the fuck?
And then also "Archer" just
did an episode about it.
And they did a whole
thing of, they were like.
- [Navi] About Tryweryn?
- Yeah.
- [Navi] 1965.
- Yeah '65
- 1965.
- They did a whole joke about
it 'cause they were like,
it's one of the most,
and they were all like,
nah, don't worry about it.
It's your justice.
- Wow.
- That's something everyone
needs to care about.
- That is something.
Now, you're all educated on Tryweryn.
That's the very basic story,
there's a lot more that
other people can tell,
more in depth story..
- I feel like when you're
from a small nation
that just doesn't get a lot of attention
from the world media in general,
'cause that's me
whenever like Thailand
gets mentioned anywhere.
I'm just happy if Thailand
is just brought up
in any kind of capacity,
I'm just everyone knows my country now!
- I love it though, they
get insanely excited.
Like anything happens, like
they're just insane, it's great.
- I remember when I went.
- I wish I had that
passion about anything.
- I remember when I went
to a con in Singapore.
- Oh and they were
shouting at you in public?
- No, no, no, no, yeah that
one but like I remember
I did a panel there and I literally,
all I literally said was hello, Singapore.
And I've never heard a crowd of people
like crying and screaming.
- That's us!
- Whoo!
It was as if fucking Elvis
Presley came on stage
and like said their country's name.
It's like, he said the country name!
- Ladies and gentlemen, Singapore.
- Whoo!
(laughs)
- Honestly, the Singapore
convention was like crazy.
- That was insane.
- Don't fucking rub it in.
I wasn't invited.
- I mean, I wasn't invited,
I was just there for the ride.
- He was just there.
- We weren't ties at this point.
We knew each other, I wasn't like that.
And plus, I was on the
other side of the world.
- I was already in Thailand.
- He was literally just next door.
- Yeah, he's like, I'm
a pop down to Singapore.
- Yeah, no, the guy literally
texted me and was like,
oh, you're in Singapore?
Think I'll pop down for a quick second.
- Yeah, it's so weird
sometimes where we are,
as Southeast Asians,
are proud of sometimes.
'Cause I swear to God, every time I meet
a fellow Southeast Asian
from a different country,
we get competitive over like
the weirdest things, right?
Because the first thing we compare
is how shit it is to drive on our roads.
I don't know why we do that!
- It's like, yeah,
you're still alive, nice.
- It's just like, oh,
this one time in Bangkok,
I was in traffic for one hour.
Oh you think one hour's bad?
When I was in Jakarta, it was
a three-hour traffic jam once.
And I'm just like, thinking
about this, I'm just like,
why are we comparing?
This is like the weirdest
dick size comparison
I can think of you.
- Oh, you survived two car crashes?
I survived four.
Like, that's not something to be proud of.
- 'Cause I was just like.
- I caused all of them.
- 'Cause after living in two years,
Sydney just went around to
other people being like,
you know, Thailand is second
on the most dangerous place
to drive in the world and I lived there.
And I'm just like, Sydney, why
are you boasting about that?
- Did she even drive there?
- She didn't even drive.
- Why are we boasting about that?
- She's saying all this
in the passenger seat.
(laughs)
- It's like when I went to go to,
my university town was number one
for heroin usage in the UK.
And we were like, yeah, number one, yeah.
(laughs)
- Yeah, number one.
Yeah, most heroin addicts!
- Heroin, number one!
- Wales, let's go!
(laughs)
Where I grew up was number one
for teen pregnancy in the UK as well.
And that was just a fact.
They were like, good, be
proud of it, be proud of it.
- Well, finally, number one in something.
- So, all of your parents
here are still teenagers?
Congratulations.
- That's kind of what
it's like in a small town.
I just realized that's
exactly the same way
as where Sydney comes from.
'Cause the first thing she
boasts about from Wisconsin,
it's just two things, we're
like number one in cheese,
biz and serial killers.
I don't think that's a good thing, Sydney.
- Being number one in cheese in the U.S.
is not, that's like saying
you're number one landlocked
country in some fucking,
I don't know, town, oh fuck
it's a terrible comparison.
- I know what you mean.
It's not something to be
like, oh wow, amazing.
I mean, what is amazing is the fact that
that state has the most serial killers.
Like that's pretty impressive, honestly.
- I liked the Midwest,
it was pretty chill.
- Where have you been in the Midwest?
- I've been to Minnesota.
- Minnesota, really?
- It's probably my favorite
state I've been to in the U.S..
- I've got deported from there.
(laughs)
Thanks Minnesota.
- Well, I don't know about you,
I had a very warm welcome in Minnesota.
- Oh, I did not.
- I was not deported.
- They bring out the red carpet.
They're like, yes, sir CdawgVA.
- They're like, your passport?
No, we don't need to
check that, go right in.
- Oh Mr Anime Man, welcome to
Minnesota, get the fuck out.
- You said they were really nice though,
when they weren't deporting you though.
- No the were nice because
they were nice about it,
at least, they were like,
"Hey, it's not your fault, man"
it happens all the time kinda thing.
But you also have to fly
immediately to Amsterdam,
and then from Amsterdam back to Tokyo.
- Are you allowed to say
why you got deported?
Is that like something
you'd like to talk about?
- Ah, just Visa mix-ups basically.
I mean like.
- You just got the wrong Visa?
- Yeah, basically I had the wrong Visa.
Apparently I asked the
immigration officer in Minnesota.
He was like, yeah, this
happens all the fucking time.
So it's like, you are
definitely not in the wrong
for not knowing this shit.
Like it is really confusing,
but he's like, just go home,
get this particular Visa
and then you'll be good
for like the next 10 years, at least.
- Sounds really cool
saying you got deported.
- Yeah.
- Sounds like you.
- Until you get deported!
- Yeah.
- But I'm sure getting
deported wasn't cool?
- No, getting deported wasn't cool.
But the fact that I literally flew
around the world in 48 hours.
You just did a fucking speed run, right?
I basically speed-ran around the world.
- Yeah, what the fuck took
them 80 days the first time?
You know what I mean?
- Just get deported bro!
- So I use the.
- Around the world
deportation hut.
- I used the deported skip here.
- The first time to the U.S.,
I didn't know you needed a Visa.
I was like, what?
So what happened was.
We did need a Visa before.
- No, we did, we need the ESTA.
- That was introduced pretty recently.
- Yeah, before the ESTA
you didn't need it.
- The first time I went to
America, you didn't need an ESTA.
- How long ago was this?
- ESTA was like 10, 15 years ago?
- Yeah, something like that.
It was within my lifetime
that the legislation changed.
- Well, 'cause you've been
traveling through Europe,
all my life, and I just
assumed you just turn out
where you want to go with a passport.
- Oh, well, yeah that makes sense.
- So, I didn't know that.
And so, I booked my flight to the U.S.,
this is when the ESTA was a thing.
Which is bullshit because
America can come to the UK,
no documentation needed, just a passport.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- When we have to go to America,
we have to get this ESTA nonsense, right?
So I'm getting all my stuff ready,
this is my first flight ever to America.
I'm on my own, I'm like oh my God,
it's midnight and my flight's at 9:00 AM.
My dad came to my room, he's
like, did you get the Visa?
I'm like, what?
What do you mean?
Yeah, you gotta get a Visa.
I'm like, no one told me this!
How do I get a Visa?
I'm like 19 as well,
I've never heard of this.
When do I have to get a Visa?
Apparently your supposed to
get it three days before?
- Yeah, you are.
- Like more than three days before.
Yeah, but luckily it came
in 15 minutes online,
so I was very lucky.
I also did that in Japan as well.
- Yeah, Aki had to do
that at the airport once.
because she realized her ESTA had run out.
- You just have a really shit track record
at getting into countries.
Like losing your passport
before we go to Japan.
- Oh, yeah, I remember that.
- I totally forgot 'cause
it only lasts for two years.
When you go to the U.S. you
have to get from most countries.
And also Canada, if you get one too?
You just apply for a thing called NASTA,
costs $15, you do it online.
If your passport is like normal,
you have no criminal record or anything,
you should get it in like 15 minutes.
- Yeah, like immediately.
- But do it three days just in case,
that's what they suggest,
and it lasts two years.
And when I moved to Japan,
I was gonna go to San
Francisco and I totally forgot
it expired until I was
on the way to the airport
when I realized it had expired.
So I was applying for it
on my phone on the way.
And luckily, right before I
was going out to check in,
I just got it.
- Ah, nice.
- I was like, nice.
- That's gold split right there.
- Yeah, I told my company, I'm like,
hey, I forgot to get the ESTA.
And they were like, what?
And I was like, yeah, so I applied for it,
it should be fine, we'll see.
- We'll see.
Luckily it all worked out.
- At least you weren't on the
plane when you realized that.
- It's weird though, 'cause
they don't ask me for it
and they don't ask me for the,
they don't ask you for
the ESTA at any point.
So I wonder, is it just on a system?
They only ask you for it
when you're immigrating
into the country that you just landed in.
- What airline did you fly with?
- I don't know, British Airways?
They've never asked me for it.
- Really?
- Because I normally get asked
when I'm queuing up to
check in if I have a Visa.
- They never ask me that.
- Oh really? I've never been asked that.
- Maybe I'm just so charming they're like,
no, no, no, go in, go in.
- Of course this charming
man doesn't have the.
- They see the brown man
and they're just like, oh.
(laughs)
Excuse me, sir.
- Or the family guy skin color thing.
- Excuse me, sir, do you have a Visa
to get into our country?
- Shit.
This is me sharing my
privilege right now, fuck.
- No, but like especially coming
from having dual citizenship
in UK and Thailand,
it just makes me realize,
man, we are very privileged
to have certain passports
because it is literally just
some passports are completely useless.
- Well, yeah, Japan is
like the most OP passport.
- It's the most powerful
passport in the world.
- But only 20% of people have them here.
Can you believe that?
The fucking audacity.
- And also, yeah, there's
so many weird other rules
that come with it.
And again, it's like you were saying,
it's the most powerful
possible in the world and yet,
barely any Japanese
people fly out of Japan
because the tourism industry
here is just so powerful.
- Go on, sorry, I interrupted you.
- I completely forgot,
I was just gonna say
that some passports are pretty OP
and that makes me jealous
of your Japanese passport
because you can get in like,
what can Japan get in without
a Visa that the UK can't?
- I'm sure there's some other countries,
put it on the screen.
Obviously we not be bothered to look.
- I don't think about this,
but I think in the UK,
it's something like 70 to 80%
of people have a passport.
In America it's like 40 or 50?
- Yeah, it was so weird for me
going to a country and just meeting people
without a passport.
- Yeah, everyone just has one in the UK,
everyone I know has one.
- In Australia as well,
almost everyone has one.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I guess it's just
like a difference in culture.
But I couldn't imagine
not having a passport.
- What are you gonna go and do in the UK?
Just go to like a field and be like, sick,
this is great vacation.
- Or I could get a passport,
go to another country
and go to that field.
- Yeah, exactly, but you know, there's.
- Have you seen our beaches?
It's amazing.
As someone who's brought up in Brighton,
don't we have amazing beaches?
You want sand beaches?
No, we got stone beaches!
- [Joey] Stone beaches.
- Can't even walk on it.
- UK tourism is the most
depressing thing on Earth.
It's just shit, it's so shit.
- Well, what would you recommend?
To someone who's never been to the UK.
- When people come to the UK-
- Don't.
(laughs)
- No, no, no, go go to London.
But that's the thing, is
that the reason why I think
the UK works as a tourist destination
is 'cause you don't
know anything about it.
When you know about the
UK, it's a terrible place.
- I think most people's
imaginations of the UK
is the queen, Harry Potter and...
- Pretty much.
- If you go to London,
you get a very sanitized view of the UK
and you can have a great time
because you only see London,
and London is very well kept.
- The charming part.
- All the fucking money's in London.
- I'd say some of the countrysides
are pretty good as well.
- But that's why I really appreciate it
when I meet people who love castles
and love going around
Wales and stuff like that,
I'm like, nice.
- [Navi] Oxford is fine.
- Oxford's nice, yeah.
- And honestly, if you wanna
go to the countryside though,
I'd say Ireland is better.
Ireland's fucking beautiful.
I've been to the countryside in Ireland
and it's so fucking nice.
- Wales is good.
(laughs)
- Patriotism showing there.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I remember when I first found out
that people just didn't live near castles,
I thought that was weird
when I first found that out.
I live near three castles
growing up and I was like.
- See out of context, that
sounds so fucking privileged.
(laughs)
- Why, what are you gonna do with it?
What it's not my castle.
- Well, no, but that's the thing.
If you said that to a Japanese
person, they'd be like,
what are you, the prince of Wales?
- No, it's 'cause there's
so many castles in the UK.
One of them was very dangerous and rundown
and climbing is just a safety hazard.
I don't know how it's still allowed,
you're allowed to go and do...
But there's one really
cool castle near me,
it's called Conwy Castle.
- I feel Wales to castles is
very much Japan to temples.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, maybe.
- Because I think if you said to someone
who has like no idea of like Asian culture
or anything like that and said,
oh yeah, there's three
temples around my house.
They'd be like, whoa, you
fucking bougie motherfucker.
- Well, Japan did have a lot of castles,
they were just burnt down.
- Well, yeah, most of them are gone.
- There is one and there's a
really big one in what Kochi,
there's a massive one.
- Yeah.
- It's really fucking cool.
- A lot of them, though, are recreation's.
That were built much, much later.
I think there's only
like a handful of castles
from that time that are
still standing to this day.
- A lot of the ones in the
UK are run down as well.
Out of the three near me,
one of them is well kept
and that's mainly for tourist reasons.
The other two are completely
run down and just like,
but it's cool that it's a bunch of rubble,
you're like, sick.
- But you can buy that, right?
You can purchase that as property?
- Some of them.
- Normally the big ones you can't,
they're normally heritage sites.
So, you can't buy them,
yhey're like public.
- And at that point,
people who buy it just buy it for a flex.
'Cause who actually lives
in a castle nowadays?
- I believe I read something
about France or something
has the most abandoned castles
and the most castles for
sale out of any country.
- Oh really?
- Apparently you can just buy chateaus
and castles and all nonsense.
- That's pretty bougie.
- All right, you say
UK is good for travel.
- No I didn't, I never said that.
- Well, what did you say?
You say, come to the UK.
- You say just go to London.
- Go to London?
- Go to London, yeah.
- Well, okay, genuine question.
Someone's coming to travel to the UK,
you wanna show them British culture,
where'd you take them to?
- First of all, the one
question you have to ask someone
who comes to the UK, is
do you drink alcohol?
- Do you drink?
- Of course, of course.
- And if you don't, you're
gonna have a bad time.
- If you love a beer, you
love drinking with people.
You can have a two week trip
and you'll have a great time.
If you don't drink alcohol,
here's a three day criteria.
- If you don't drink alcohol,
I hope you like castles.
- You know, I genuinely think,
'cause you can do nearly
everything in London
that's worth seeing in one day.
- Like, one or two days.
- Three days if you don't wanna rush.
But all the major things
are within walking distance of each other.
- Do you take them to
like the tourist sites
and everything like that?
Yeah, very fast, I'm like,
here's Buckingham Palace, have a look.
All right, here's the Big Ben have a look,
it's shit, don't pay it,
it's like $90 to go on it.
It's a rip off, don't do it.
- Well, when we went it
was in fucking scaffolding.
So I didn't even get to see it.
- Oh and London Eye,
sorry London Eye's shit.
Big Ben looks pretty cool
actually, I like that.
But you know, normally it's
like, you wanna see Big Ben?
We can go and drink in the
park in front of Big Ben,
you wanna do that?
- Yeah, that's cool.
- There's the arcade that's now closing.
- It's closed now, yeah.
- Is that the one with Shrek at the front?
- Yeah.
- [All] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, that's an arcade.
- It was a Namco Funscape,
there was a shit arcade,
it was all right, but it's closing.
But it was the only arcade.
What else can you do in London?
- Dunno.
- Maybe take them on the boat.
- On the boat?
- So you know how
there's public transport,
there's the tube?
Part of the network is a boat.
- Oh, like a ferry system?
- That you can just cross
the, yeah, it goes from,
I think, Greenwich to
Westminster or something?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, Greenwich, I really
like taking people to Greenwich.
Greenwich is a really nice area.
You can go and I can be like,
look, here's where time star is.
(laughs)
- Yeah, that's all I know about Greenwich.
- It's a very nice area
actually, it's really well done.
- [Navi] There's a warship
in Belfast, in front of the.
- Belfast's like six hours away,
you can't go to the Belfast.
- [Navi] The warship.
- The Cutty Sark.
- [Navi] It's right in
front of the, not palace,
right next to the bridge.
- Greenwich?
- [Navi] It's not Greenwich.
- You're talking about the HMS Belfast?
- Yeah.
- Oh, that one.
- I don't know.
- Don't know that one either.
- If you go to Greenwich as well,
there's a massive boat
that's been restored on land,
a pirate ship, it's fucking massive.
- Damn.
- [Navi] Apparently they
actually collabed with Azur Lane.
- The UK government should
just hire me, I'll make right.
- What would you add?
- Spoons, go to Wetherspoons.
- Tesco meal deal?
- Tesco.
- Tesco meal deal.
- Honestly, I would take
them to Spoons as well.
- Spoons is great.
- You did take us to Spoons.
- Yeah, I did!
I should just ask you Joey,
where did we take you again?
- No, we did shit with
Joey, it was terrible.
- We went to the Shrek arcade and Spoons.
- We went to the fucking
gaming bar as well.
- The gaming bar.
- It was terrible.
- It was literally just
a pub with a Wi in it.
(laughs)
- You can game in that bar.
- British culture, man.
- Yeah, it's sick.
- 'Cause like pubs in London
are where all the best food are as well.
It's all the best food.
- Dude, fair, that pub
did have some good food.
- 'Cause the way I see it,
right, because the way I see it,
when I go travel to a place,
I very rarely want to go
to the big tourist spots.
- I Just wanna eat.
- I want cool places to
see, but just like not the,
here's just a landmark
that everyone takes a
fucking picture around.
I just want cool local places.
And as someone who lived in
London for close to three years,
if it doesn't revolve around alcohol,
I don't know the cool
places to take people.
- Oh, there's Afternoon Tea?
- Oh Afternoon Tea, actually that.
- The home of Afternoon Tea.
- Yeah, of course, of course,
I completely forgot about Afternoon Tea.
That's pretty much the only
part of like British food
that I'm just like, yep,
Afternoon Tea fucking slaps.
- To be fair, I feel Australia
would be the exact same thing
if it wasn't for the fact that we have
some of the best beaches in the world.
'Cause at least we can
take you to the beach.
- You got it easy, man.
- Yeah, but if you don't like beaches,
then I hope you like drinking.
'Cause we're going to
be doing a lot of that.
- Yeah. It's kinda hard, I've had friends,
normally Americans, who are
like, no, I don't drink,
and I'm like, I honestly
don't know what to do.
I can show you Big Ben.
- I have the same thing when
friends come to Australia
and I have to take them around
like a couple of times I'm like,
do you wanna see Sydney Opera House?
- I swear, I'm not an alcoholic,
but it's just the culture.
- No, no, it is.
- I don't know what to do.
- That's kinda why I wanted
to move out of England
because it just felt
like if you didn't drink,
then there was nothing
else to do to have fun
or just like chill out,
that's a big thing.
- No one does anything
on weekdays in the UK.
Like weekdays is strictly for working
and then going home and being depressed.
That's all you do.
- Now, I feel that's just.
- No one goes out in the
UK, it's always the weekend.
- Oh really, like even after work?
- No, no one really goes out.
- Really?
- Yeah, I agree with that.
- It's normally older people,
they normally will go
off to the pub after work
when they're like 40s,
'cause of their lot.
- I would have you know,
some people will go to the pub after work.
- No, I know, if I worked in
office, I would love to go.
But as a YouTuber, no one
wanted to go out in the weekday.
So it was an absolute uphill
battle trying to get people
to do anything in the UK.
- So you have to wait till the weekend.
- Yes, so I never did
anything during the week.
I just worked on videos, I
think, and played video games.
I don't really know what I did.
(laughs)
I don't know what I did in London.
- What did I do?
- What did I do in London?
I don't know, went to coffee?
We have a lot of good cafes.
- Do we?
- Compared to Europe?
- We are, we were in Europe.
- You guys are European.
- We were in Europe.
- Well, we're not in Europe anymore.
- Yeah, 'cause it's easy to get stuff
from like Italy and whatever.
- It's true, that's true.
That's the one thing I miss
about, that sucks about Japan
is that importing anything from Europe
is like 20 times the price.
- [Joey] Well, yeah.
- It's like a block of cheese
that I would pay 10 pounds for in the UK
imported from France,
which is seen as like a
luxury, expensive item.
- Yeah, fucking first
time I was in Australia,
it's like, literally, off
the side of the planet.
- It's depressing, I bought a
wine bottle and I looked at it
and it was like 30 pounds in the UK.
And it was like 90 pounds here in Japan.
And I was like, fuck.
- Jesus Christ.
- Yeah.
- Fuck.
- Which is such a flip to whenever,
well, when someone's gonna
come visit us in Japan.
Because like when a friend
comes to visit in Japan,
you're just like, what kind
of experience do you want?
'Cause like you can do anything.
- Do you wanna see nature or
do you wanna see the city?
Do you wanna see culture?
- But do you ever get sick
ushering people around Japan?
'Cause you were always the go-to guy
who had to take people around Japan.
- Yeah, I was, but after a
while, it depends who I'm with.
If I'm with a person who I'm
not super buddy-buddy with,
and obviously I want
them to have a good time
and have a good impression.
But if I'm just like,
it's just like a fucking
mate from school or whatever,
then I used to do this thing
where I would take them
to all these places,
but then pretend I couldn't
speak a word of Japanese
just to piss them off.
'Cause I was like,
I don't wanna be the translator
this week, so you know what?
Let's see how you like it.
So, we would go to a restaurant
and I would be reading the menu
and I'll be like (speaks
in foreign language).
So, you just fucking
pretend that I was foreign.
'Cause if I don't speak Japanese,
they'll never fucking know.
So that was just like, come
on Joey, just fucking help us.
Help me translate this fucking thing.
And I was like, (speaks in
foreign language), I'm sorry.
- Yeah, Japan is just like
local guide, easy mode.
You go to a fucking family
mart and they blow their minds.
- Yeah, right?
I just take 'em like, Ikebukuro
and it's done for the day.
- Yeah, I know right.
- It's so easy.
- One place in Tokyo, and
that's their entire itinerary
done for the day.
- Yeah, honestly.
- Take them to a ramen place,
though, oh my gosh ramen.
- Well that's the thing, if
you take them to like, Shibuya,
you're easily like, two
days you can spend there.
If you take them to Akihabara,
that's a whole day again.
- Akihabara is several days.
- Yeah, that's true.
- If you go there for
one day and they're like,
"Can we go back to Akihabara please?"
- I miss when I thought Akihabara
was like super fun and amazing.
- You don't think so anymore?
- I miss that as well.
- Well, it's just 'cause all the figures,
you know that the price is
always cheaper elsewhere.
- I've just found that the more times
I've gone to Akihabara,
the more I realized
that there was just so much
cool, hidden shit there.
That really, if you're
not there with someone
who knows the area really well,
it really just does seem like
here's the place to buy anime figurines.
Here's the place to buy weird shit.
- Yeah.
- I just don't have the
time to explre it anymore.
- Also, nearly all the restaurants
I've been to in Akihabara
are severely disappointing.
- Fucking awesome.
- I mean awful, awful.
(laughs)
I said awes, awful.
- I've had pretty the
worst meals in Japan,
consistently, in Akihabara.
- Yeah, same here.
- I don't know why, I think
'cause it's just on the front
and then everyone's
like, come in our store.
- Well that's the thing, no one
really thinks to themselves,
oh, I want a really nice
meal, let's go to Akihabara.
- Also, I hate the maids who are like,
come in our store, please, please!
- Yeah, that is really annoying.
- And they're like, (speaks in Japanese).
And I'm like, fuck off!
(laughs)
- If it's (speaks in
Japanese), they'd give this,
fuck off!
- I'm British, I say to my head,
I'm like, please leave me alone.
- Human interaction, get
outta here, get outta here.
- Be gone ().
(laughs)
- One time we walked
past and there was a maid
that was like, Joey?
Do you remember that?
- No.
- What do you say, you were
there, she started screaming,
like one of the maids.
- Oh the maid who recognized me?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't remember.
How do you remember this?
- Wait, no actually what
happened was, I was with you,
we were walking and I saw
the girl looking at you
and we kept on walking
and then I just heard her go, "Joey?".
- Oh yes, I do remember!
- And I feel like you
didn't pay any attention,
you were like, whatever
and just kept walking.
(laughs)
- And then I was like,
(speaks in Japanese)
- I do remember that
actually because it's like,
yeah, I heard her say my
name, but I thought like,
I didn't hear it as my name
until I walked past her.
And then I processed, I was like,
I think she was calling my name.
But then at that point it
was too late to turn around
and be like, me?
I don't wanna be that guy.
- I'm famous, yes.
- I was like, I'll just be
the cool guy and keep walking.
- I feel so unguarded whenever
I get recognized in Japan.
'Cause I'm just like what, what?
- It really catches me of guard.
- Yeah, it really is scary.
- 'Cause I know like, one, it's surprising
to hear someone speak English as well here
or just on the streets, and
two, someone who speaks English
and also recognizes you.
And it's, especially I think,
since Trash Taste has started as well.
Like, I don't know how I'm gonna handle
going to my next anime convention
and there's just gonna be
like, 70 million people calling me Grant,
and I'm not gonna be able
to tell the difference.
Like if they're just meming
or if they actually
think my name is Grant.
- I hope at the airport,
they're like welcome Garnt, Grant, sorry.
- Welcome, Grant.
(laughs)
- Yeah, 'cause people
already fuck up my username.
They're like, yo, you're
the anime guy, right?
Or it's like, your the animae dude.
I'm like, I can't wait to just be called
all these fucking nicknames.
I'm just like, do you actually know I am,
or are you just like taking the piss?
'Cause sometimes I don't even know.
Like when a person
comes up to me and goes,
are you the anime guy?
I don't know if I'm supposed
to go, I'm the Anime Man,
or if I'm supposed to go nah.
- Who's that, who's that?
- I'm not that guy.
- Who is that?
- I don't know who that is.
- I don't know who that guy is.
- Why hello there, it is I, Anime Zone.
And while Connor's not here,
I'm going to hijack this
podcast to talk about anime.
'Cause you know what?
This episode is sponsored by Crunchyroll.
This fall season
Crunchyroll is simulcasting
a bunch of new seasons of classics
like "Boruto", "Case
Closed" and of course,
the "Demon Slayer: Kimetsu
No Yaiba Mugan Train TV Arc"
and "Entertainment District Arc".
Not to miss this season,
"One Piece" is airing it's
one thousandth episode.
Can you believe it?
And a lineup of fresh
titles like "Platinum End",
"Sakugan" and "Blade Runner Black Lotus".
As you know, I am the last
remaining Trash Taste member
who actually watches anime.
And I know that "Platinum
End" comes from a manga
that was made by the same
team that made "Death Note".
So I am very curious
and hyped to watch it.
As always, you get the biggest
catalog of anime content
with over 30,000 animated
episodes available to you
to watch in both sub and dub.
You can watch all these
titles for free on Crunchyroll
or try their 14-day free trial
of their premium membership
to skip all the ads and access
simulcasting with Japan.
Follow the link on screen
or go to crunchyroll.com/trashtaste
to start watching animate today,
because you're gonna be doing better
than the rest of the boys.
That's crunchyroll.com/trashtaste.
Thank you to Crunchyroll
for sponsoring us today,
back to the episode.
- Yeah, have you guys ever been recognized
in your home country?
- Have we spoke about this
on Trash Taste before?
- I don't know.
But I feel like it's gonna
be even more insane now.
- Tell us Garnt, tell us, tell us, yeah.
Tell me when you've been
recognized in the UK.
- Have you actually been?
- Yeah, I've been recognized once, I feel,
I think in an Argos in Brighton.
- Argos?
- Yeah.
- Holy fuck.
- What's an Argos?
- Oh God, it's a terrible store.
So it's, the whole gimmick of this store
is that you don't actually
get to look at the products
due to the warehouse,
but you get to look at
the massive 10 page,
no not 10 page, 400 page
book, and you get to pick.
- Oh, is this the place
where you were talking
about like a Christmas gift or whatever?
- Yeah it's fucking terrible.
- Yeah, basically just imagine Amazon.
- IRL.
- Except, you have to go there
and you don't have a computer
screen to browse everything.
You just have a massive book.
- Lord knows how they're still
in business with that model.
- That sounds very outdated.
- It's kinda like the Blockbuster now.
- So, you got recognized in Argos?
- Yeah, it's really weird,
just one of the cashiers
recognize me, it's not
a very exciting story.
- Give you discount?
- Huh?
- They give you a discount?
- No.
- Fuck.
- Have you ever gotten that before?
Where someone working at an
establishment recognize you
and you got a thing out of it?
- No, but if they do,
I'm very open to that.
- I've heard stories
about, now, about some of,
well, Sydney just went back to America
and apparently she was just in
a bar and she got recognized.
- Oh sick.
(laughs)
- Oh shit, but that's not
good, that's not good,
it's Sydney's content.
- Yeah, yeah. Well, no, she got recognized
because she was obviously my fiance
and she was just, and all
the guy said was just,
"Oh, are you Sydney?",
and she's like, yeah.
"Oh, where's Garnt?".
(laughs)
She's like, "Oh, he didn't come here".
And he was like, "Oh,
say hi to Garnt for me".
- Ah, no!
- Don't do that!
- Yeah, don't do that.
- I hate it when people would be like,
say hi to Joey and Garnt for me.
I'm like, and what?
What am I gonna say?
- Yeah, by the way, a random
dude I just met says hi.
It's like, what do we say to that?
Look, we appreciate you guys
coming up to us and saying, hi.
That's cool and all.
But don't make us be the
messenger for another person,
no one appreciates that.
- You know, the 800th
century, I'm not a messenger.
I'm not like here to
convey messages for you.
I got recognized one time
at midnight on a bus,
which is terrifying.
- Oh God.
- I was going to the gym.
And yeah, the bus went right
outside my house to the gym,
it was perfect, it was 24
hours as well so it was good.
And I was on my way back from the gym.
I was extremely sweaty
and there's only two people
on this bus, me and him.
And he was right at the back
wearing a hoodie in the back, just like.
- Ah, shit.
- And I was like, what the fuck.
Then I'm sitting close to
the front on the second level
and I'm just listening to music.
And I'm like, yeah, mmhmm.
And then I feel like on my back,
like a tapping.
- Well, that's scary.
- And I'm like (startles).
I'm like what, what?
He's like, "Are you Cdawg?".
And I was like, "Yeah, yeah,
I'm Cdawg, what's up?".
And he's like, "Love your videos".
And I'm like, "Thanks, man".
And he just walked off.
(laughs)
I was like, I was like, what?
- That's so scary.
- I was like, what?
He was like still hoodie and everything on
when he came up to me.
It's like, "Are you Cdawg?".
- Just brick shithouse.
- Yeah, he was massive.
- And I was like, "Ah, thanks man nice."
And I was like, this is my house.
- I got recognized in Akihabara.
Used to get recognized a lot, obviously.
- Yeah, every time we
used to go with you there.
- I always, that's when my people are.
- I feel like Akihabara's
like a cheat code.
'Cause that's like
saying you got recognized
at an anime convention.
- Yeah, because it's also,
Akihabara's surprisingly
has the most foreigners.
- Yeah, it does.
I mean, it's one of the
most sensationalized,
wacky to look at places in Tokyo.
But I was recognized, I get recognized
pretty much every time I go to Akihabara.
But the one time I went to, you know,
I was like, running a
little short on my hentai.
Might pop into a Melonbooks,
which is a store where you can buy hentai
and peruse the goods.
- Oh shit, are you The Anime Man?
- Yeah, and as I was
perusing through some stuff,
I got a tap on the shoulder
and he's like, "Are you Joey?"
And I'm like.
- I thought you were gonna be like,
the lowest section's over there.
- Wrong place man.
And he's like, yeah.
Well, I'm like, yeah, I am, hi.
And I was like, oh no, of all...
And I was like holding a doujin
I was about to buy as well.
I'm like, worst timing and
he had like a bag as well.
So he obviously just like
finished at the cash register.
And the guy was like,
"What are you doing here?".
I'm like, "What the fuck do
you think I'm doing here?"
- I jack off, we all jack off.
- Like really, are you
sure you're a fan of me?
'Cause if you are,
you wouldn't know exactly
what I am doing here.
I am holding the thing I am
about to buy, you can see that.
So all I said was just,
just buying some hentai?
(laughs)
And he was like, "Ah, sick
dude, all right bey!".
And he just walked out.
- It's just like, what kind of interaction
can you have in that place?
'Cause I have exactly the same experience,
'cause the place I can
recognized the most is that.
- Yeah, is that Melonbooks, right?
- It's that store!
- I'd be recognized like
three times in a Melonbooks.
And I'm like, why?
Is it just known?
- Is that just a doujin store?
- Yeah, Melonbooks is like a huge.
- It's a complete doujin store.
Basically when Sydney's
just running out of ideas
for content, she just goes there
and she's like, oh, this shit.
- And then the cashier's
like, is Garnt with you?
(laughs)
- Yeah, Melonbooks and Toranoana
are the two big, big
hentai stores in Akihabara.
- I always get recognized,
and I haven't been recognized
often but when I do,
it's always when I look like shit.
It's never when I've made
an effort to look good,
it's never in the JoJo suit.
It's never when I've got my drip game on.
It's when I'm in fucking sweatpants.
- But like how often.
- Yeah, how often are you in ().
- How often is that though Connor?
- Listen.
(laughs)
- I, every single day I leave the house.
I remember one time I went
to a Sainsbury's near me,
which is just a normal supermarket.
- Yeah.
- And I was wearing sweatpants,
flip flops, you know,
the shit which I actually
don't even normally do that.
I would normally put the
effort in to wear jeans.
- Yeah.
- Actually, no, I lie.
This is back when I thought
that wearing jeans was a luxury.
If I was working.
- Why is it a luxury?
- 'Cause those are work pants.
- Actually I'm gonna, I'm
just gonna go on a detour,
'cause it was a story anyway.
But I basically got recognized
in sweat pants, not funny.
- Is this why you refuse
to wear washed jeans?
'Cause it's a luxury?
- No, no, that's a different shit take.
- No, no, no, that's not a shit
take, let's go right there.
So I had this thing for
a very long time where
this isn't a meeting,
this is a general thing.
I used to just only wear like
sweatpants when I was at home.
If I wasn't leaving the
house, I wouldn't wear jeans,
I would just wear sweat pants.
- I still do that.
- But now I changed my mind.
And now I only wear jeans in the house.
- What?
How do you bring yourself to do that?
- I do that.
- What?
- Because what happened.
- I always wear jeans.
- What happened, is that I
started just feeling like shit,
I'm just like not working.
And so I was like, maybe if I
like dress like I'm not slob,
I might work a little better.
- You laugh but it's a real fucking thing.
- And it actually worked.
- Like I wear jeans not because I want to,
but because it's the only
way I'm gonna look good.
- But when you're wearing
a pair of jeans nicely,
they feel better than anything.
- I feel like my day hasn't
started until I put on my jeans.
Sometimes I try to work.
- Like an American fighting for freedom.
I'm just haven't started my day
until I put on my denim jeans.
- Honestly, sometimes I try to work
and I'm in like sweat pants
or sometimes just in my fucking boxes
'cause I sleep in my boxes
and I just don't get anything done.
As soon as I put on my
jeans, the day has started.
- Amen.
- I am ready to work.
- I don't know, man.
I just wake up and go, time to work,
and then I just start working.
- If you go to jeans.
- Mind over matter man.
- Yeah, but if you go to jeans.
- You just work harder.
- And like one time I even went so far
as to start wearing nice shirts.
- Like a suit shirt.
- Yeah, but the suit shirts
when I was making videos.
'Cause I was convinced
that this is the next step
to increasing my productivity.
Yeah, turns out it didn't
work, I just hated it.
But I found the happy
medium at jeans and a shirt.
I felt like if I can dress enough.
- Are we talking like a
t-shirt or a college shirts?
- No like this.
- Oh , yeah, yeah.
- But I think the sweatpants
were the big player,
because I basically got to the mindset of,
I wanna wear outfits
that I could just go out
to any social gathering or
I can wear this to anywhere.
And so, I felt like it
helped my productivity.
So if you work at home a lot
and you've gotten into the habit
of sweatpants-ing all the
time, maybe give a try.
- Just try wearing what
you would wear to work.
- Okay, but what would you
do during the summer then?
- I still wear jeans.
- You still wear full on jeans?
- I'm not gonna wear jorts.
- Are you gonna wear jorts?
- Fuck no.
Jeans, AC blasting.
- I mean, I wear whatever I would wear
to the Trash Tatse office.
That's basically my dress code at home.
But I would never wear
anything too comfy, I guess.
- Comfort is the enemy of productivity.
- Well, 'cause if I'm wearing sweatpants,
I feel like I should be in my bedroom
or on the couch.
- Yeah, no I get that.
- Watching TV just chilling out.
- One thing I do do in the morning
to get me into the work
mode if I'm at home all day
is that I don't wear like my pajama shirt.
I like change to a different shirt.
- What's a pajama shirt?
You have a pajama shirt?
- Yeah, just like old
shirts that I don't wear.
- You wear shirts to bed?
Why don't you do that?
- I wear shirts to bed.
- Why?
- 'Cause I don't wanna.
- Why do people do this?
- 'Cause I don't wanna be naked.
- Because it just feels.
- I wear boxers, just boxes.
- I don't know, It just
doesn't feel comfortable.
It feels like, unless
I'm in a sleeping bag,
I don't have enough cover over me.
- Yeah, I feel really bare.
- Yeah.
- And unprotected.
- Like boxers? Boxers I'm fine with.
- I love using the body
parts as temperature control.
So I put some out, put some in,
depending on how cold or hot I need to be.
- Okay, but do you, do
you wear boxers to bed?
- Yeah, sometimes naked, sometimes boxers.
- See, I need wear boxers to bed.
Sleeping completely
naked just feels weird.
- It's a getting used to thing.
'Cause the nut sack is
a very delicate thing
to kind of like.
(laugh)
You laugh, but that's the main problem.
Your nuts go everywhere and sometimes
they're more elastic than other times.
- What?
- Sometimes you just
don't want your nut sack
rubbing against your leg.
You know like, I dunno, for me.
- Are your nuts so huge
that they're like a
fucking sack of potatoes,
like oh fuck it's gone away.
- I've got to forklift
them out of the way.
- When I'm not wearing a shirt to sleep,
it just feels weird to feel
my own skin on my skin.
- No, I get that.
Like you know, it's
exactly the same thing.
- But the only time I will.
- What the fuck, you've been brainwashed.
- The only time where I will
go to bed without a shirt on
is if it's excruciatingly hot,
to the point where even the AC on blast
isn't gonna do it for me.
- What?
- To me, I need some fabric on me
to stop myself from touching myself.
- Use the bedsheets.
- No, no, it's an embrace.
You're lightly embraced by the shirt.
It's like, go to sleep.
- It's like an extra layer
of skin that you're not,
that sounded really like.
- Epidermis 2.0 right here.
- I feel like you're just
giving me a very shit reason
as to why you wear a shirt to bed.
- It's comfortable, end of story.
- I don't understand why
you would feel uncomfortable
without a shirt on.
- And then another thing,
sometimes if I'm not wearing a shirt,
my body gets even hotter.
Because you have like a
natural body temperature
and if it's like skin on skin,
sometimes it's like a loop system
where it warms itself up a bit more.
I don't know if that's just me.
- I think that's bullshit,
I think you've got
insulation with more shirt.
- It's like an eddy current up here.
(laughs)
- Surely the shirt keeps
in the heat more, no?
- No, I mean like insulation
works both ways, right?
Like if you put, if you put
a jacket on a snowman, right?
It insulates the heat in,
it insulates the cold in.
- They actually say to preserve body heat,
like in super cold
temperatures when you sleep,
it's actually better to sleep
naked than to wear something.
- I just, why wouldn't you wanna.
I just think that you're
meant to sleep naked.
I juts thought that's what
you're supposed to do.
- Where'd you get this idea from?
- [Joey] The fucking cavemen.
- Isn't that how God intended?
- Well, God sleeps naked.
- Why wear clothes then?
- It just seems like a lot more effort
to be wearing clothes to bed,
why are you complicating it?
- Effort?
- Yeah, just go naked.
- How hard is it to
put a shirt on for you?
- I just think why are you
adding shirts into an equation
that doesn't need it? You know.
- Why do you use blankets then?
- Okay, question then.
- Yeah, why need blankets?
- All right, here's a question then.
- Why not just sleep on a slab of rock?
- No, I have a serious question.
- So then when you start
doing the business,
don't you just throw the shirt off?
- Yeah.
- No, that just seems like a lot of work.
(laughs)
I'm always ready.
- It's two seconds, it's
just whoop, you're done.
- When you jack off, do you wear a shirt?
- Depends where I am.
- It's never really part of
the equation of jacking off.
I'm just like, do I have my shirt on?
- I feel like I'm like the Michellin man
when I'm jacking off wearing a shirt,
I feel like I'm constricted.
I'm like, fucking hell,
get this shirt off me.
- Do you fucking bulk up when you.
- Have you never done the
business with a shirt on?
- I have, I don't like it.
It feels like I'm in some
kind of like constriction.
(laughs)
I don't like it at all.
- You don't like it?
- No, it feels dreadful.
- I don't mind it.
- Yeah, sometimes you need
to, something it's nice.
- There's a reason why, in
porn, they take the short off.
It's 'cause you want to get like.
- Well, that's because they're
on fucking camera mate.
- Yeah, but also.
- Are you on camera?
- I might be.
Don't know what I'm into.
- Gotta know I'm fucking.
- Next sponsor.
But it's also like when
you're pooping sometimes,
you have to take your shirt off.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I get that.
- But that's more of just like.
- The same kind of energy.
- Well, that's the
thing, if it gets intense
I'll take the shirt off.
- Not every poop, you need
to take your shirt off.
- I would prefer if possible.
- Speak for yourself.
- When you wake up, right,
and you have the first poop,
do you take the shirt off when you do it?
Or do you just like to.
- No.
- No, I keep it on.
- Like the shirt-taking-off-poops
are for the poops that fight back.
It's when you need to like,
you need that extra push and that.
- Those are the poops that are
like, no, I'm staying here.
The ones in the morning
are kind of just like,
all right, it was a good night.
- I generally prefer to just
take it off when I poop anyway.
- Why?
- Not during the day, if I'm
out in a public restroom.
I'm like, time to undress.
(laughs)
- Connor goes for a poop and just
and he takes off the
JoJo suit, puts it over,
takes off the tie, takes off the shirt.
- And I'd still poop faster than Garnt.
- I don't know, it's
just a placebo, right?
I just feel more comfortable
wearing a shirt to bed.
I dunno what it is.
- I think you've nerfed yourself.
- In what way have we nerfed ourselves?
- How?
- I feel like you've nerfed yourself.
- No, 'cause I can poop
without any requirements.
- You know what it also is as well?
- It doesn't sound like that.
Because it sounds like the requirement is
that you need to take a shirt off.
You need to have nothing on.
- I just prefer it.
- That's literally a requirement.
I can sleep naked, I just
prefer to have a shirt on..
- What of you're stranded without a shirt.
- Then I'll sleep with my shirt off.
He's the reason.
- But you'll be
complaining the whole time.
- He's the reason as well though,
because I've actually experienced this
where in the middle of the
night, we're in Japan, right?
Earthquakes, right?
They happened all the fucking time, right?
If there's a massive earthquake
in the middle of the night,
I don't wanna be that weirdo
running out of my house,
butt fucking naked.
- You have time to grab your clothes.
- Well the why don't
you just wear the shirt
at that point, then, if you have the time
to wear a shirt escaping
from an earthquake,
why not just sleep with it.
- I'm not Jason Bourne,
I don't need to be ready
for combat situations
every fucking night.
I haven't got a drawer full
of passports ready to go
in case I need to be deported.
This t-shirt is on the floor,
this one extra second of
putting on the t-shirt,
which I can do on the way to
the elevator or some shit.
I don't need to.
- On the way to an
elevator in an earthquake.
- Nothing is, I'm not walking downstairs.
- I just have this mental
image of just like,
if an earthquake happens when
Connor is either sleeping
or on the toilet, it's just gonna be
that scene from Borat out all over again.
(laughs)
Connor just emerges butt naked.
- Completely butt naked.
- If I'm shitting in the
middle of an earthquake,
I'm taking my chances,
I'm gonna carry on doing what I'm doing.
I'm not, why would I run out?
I feel like running out
is just a stupid idea.
Just stay in your house.
Maybe, yeah, if you die, you die.
- No, it is a very specific situation.
- No, of course.
- When we evacuated in LA,
I felt like we did not need to evacuate.
I felt like we should've
just stayed in our room.
I dunno what they what the
recommended guideline is,
but I'm pretty sure running
down to the bottom floor
is not the right idea.
- [Navi] Nor is the elevator.
- Yeah, you can't use the elevator.
- [Joey] I ran all the way down.
- Navi ran 51 stories.
- I would say not using the
elevator during an earthquake
is probably at the top
of things not to do.
- Yeah, I just had shit to do after it,
so I really wanted to get down fast.
- Those Chick-fil-A nuggets
weren't gonna eat themselves.
- That as well.
And also, the moment that
I was immediately put off
going down the stairs,
was when we ran past
the American family
and that guy was acting
like we were in a Hollywood movie.
And he had like three
kids and he was like,
kids stay with me, stay with your daddy!
We're gonna go down together,
as a team, hold hands!
And I was like, I'm not
being in this guy's movie.
I'm gonna do my own thing.
I don't want to be part of this.
That's when I decided that
I was not doing the stairs.
- It was a pretty tense situation.
But the moment I heard that dad say that.
I was just like, pfft.
- The earthquake had ended,
it was like, whatever.
I was not really scared anymore.
The building was still shaking,
but I was like, whatever,
it's not a big deal.
- The building's built for it.
- Yeah, the building's built
different to withstand it.
- To withstand those, yeah.
- So I was pretty confident
that we were gonna be fine.
So I was like, whatever.
I think I'll take the elevator.
I realized that.
- Don't take emergency advice from Connor.
- I'm not recommending
it, I just, I'm lazy.
- He just does it anyway.
- I was just, you know,
I felt confident enough
that I was gonna be fine.
And if I died, you know, sure,
I can have my Darwin award
in peace, 'cause I'm dead.
- I can kind of relate to that
in like a tangential sense
where you just willingly
put your life in danger,
just for a bit of convenience.
- I don't feel like he was
endanger, I didn't feel that way.
- Because living in Thailand,
this is going on a complete tangent.
- Every time you get in the car.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- Take your shirt off.
- No, no, that's not
risking your life, okay?
Bangkok is the only place I've lived in
where people willingly risked
their lives on the daily
by taking a motorcycle taxi daily
in some of the most
dangerous roads in the world
just to save yourself
30 minutes of traffic.
And we do that on a daily
and I do that on a daily.
I'm just like, that's weird
when you think about it.
- I can't really describe
why I just wanted to take the elevator.
But I think I just realized,
I could either walk
down 70 floors of stairs
or I could just risk it
and take the elevator.
And I think at that point in time, to me,
taking 70 flights of stairs
was not worth my life.
- Well, I mean, I can't argue against that
'cause I also went in the elevator.
(laughs)
- I think it was one of those
things where it was like,
Connor's going in the elevator.
All right if he's stupid
enough to risk his life,
I guess I feel confident enough
where I'll go in with it.
I can blame Connor if I die.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I don't know, I know that
I shouldn't do it, but I did.
- I mean, we ended up
not going down anyway.
- Yeah, so what ended up
happening was cosmic justice,
is that the elevator to get down,
you had to go up to the
70th floor, to the lobby,
to then get down and when
we got to the 70th floor,
they stopped all the elevators.
- So basically, we went down
about 35 stairs for nothing.
So basically just instant karma.
- Instant karma compilation.
- And then we waited 10 minutes
and the elevator started working.
- Yeah, and then there was no problems.
- And I was very delighted by it.
- [Navi] I literally
looked back and was like,
where the fuck are they?
- Meanwhile, Navi was like,
went down 70 flights of stairs,
turned around, was like.
- But you know, when
stuff like that happens,
I feel like I don't wanna
be that guy who's panicking
and running around like all these people.
- No that's the worst thing to do.
I just feel like this is.
- Dopey sheep.
- Wake up sheeple.
- This is how you're inviting
a shitty situation to happen.
You know, I also don't wanna
try my chances on the road.
'Cause when you leave the hotel,
you're just facing the road.
I don't want to try my
chance with stuff falling
or people driving on the
road in an earthquake.
I was pretty content
that my room was fine.
I was like, oh whatever.
- Well, that's the
thing, in some situations
it's actually more dangerous
to go out on the road
because in the case with Japan,
we have so much like electrical
wiring from the roads
that if those fall and snap,
they can easily electrocute you
fucking traffic signs
can come down, hurt you.
- I feel like the safest
place is just to probably be
on the ground floor.
- Yes.
- Of a building.
- I dunno but you get way more
like earthquake vibrations
on the first floor.
- Do you?
- Yeah, the higher up the
building, the less you get.
You just get swaying if you're up top.
And when you're down below
you get the fucking violent shaking.
- Yeah, the best thing
to do is to just go out
into like a really, really open field.
- I feel like this is a point in my life
where I'm just like,
I don't know if I should
listen to this advice.
- Well, 'cause the really tall buildings
are built on like rolling mechanics.
So when the building, you
fucking experienced it.
- What'd you mean?
- The hotel we stayed in?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's built on rollers so that
when the earthquake happens,
it starts rolling.
- Yeah, but on the ground floor.
Sometimes you literally don't
even feel the earthquake.
Because there's no swaying
or anything like that.
- No, 'cause you're getting like
the actual fucking earth shaking.
- That's not what it feels
like on the ground floor.
- Yeah, it does!
- You've had an earthquake
on the ground floor, right?
- Yeah.
- It feels very violently shaking.
- Yeah, but it's kind of the
same as being on the building.
- When I experienced both in Japan,
I definitely prefer in LA
when the building was just swaying.
I liked that a lot more.
- I was literally on the street
and sometimes I didn't even notice
that there was an
earthquake when people will.
- What?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
'Cause there's nothing to
like, how can I put this?
There's nothing to put your perspective
in that you're in an earthquake.
You just feel a bit wobbly.
- The floor is moving.
- The floor doesn't move, it shakes.
- Does it?
- It shakes but a lot of the times
you can't actually see it moving
until you look at something.
- Yeah, there's nothing to
ground your perspective.
- Whereas, if you're in a building,
you can see other buildings doing this.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I don't really mind though.
Most of the times, I don't even
realize I'm in an earthquake
until I have something to
like ground that perspective.
Sometime like living in Japan,
sometimes I just get up, get a head rush,
I'm like, ooh, was that an earthquake?
- Like do you ever get that?
- Yeah, but because there's
so many light earthquakes.
But you know when you're
getting an earthquake,
'cause it used to be like, just fucking.
- My mom has this story
of when she was in school,
she was like running along
the tracks at school.
And you know when you're running,
your entire world is doing this.
So she was running and she was looking
at the school building
and then she stopped
and the building just kept doing this
and she realized she was in an earthquake.
And she didn't realize until she stopped
because to her perspective,
it's already going up and down.
But then, I think again,
it's that like perspective
of being, that's not moving
the way it's intended to.
- But also, the swaying
and all that stuff,
I don't really give a shit,
as long as the building
isn't falling down.
- Yeah.
- And I just don't want my stuff to break.
- Well, yeah, that's the biggest thing
is just shit falling down, isn't it?
- Yeah, that's why if I ever
knew there was an earthquake,
I would just rush to my like camera gear.
I'm like hold my shirt and coat.
- Protect, protect.
- JoJo figures, please.
- Me and my anime figures.
- No, no!
- Those are the real
casualties in earthquakes.
- I had those 400, $500 Jojo figures
that were like very finely balanced.
That were balanced, the
weight was like this.
So that the center of
gravity was very worrying.
And during earthquakes,
I immediately had to just like
go to them if I was there.
And during, we had one
pretty big earthquake
and I was surprised 'cause
my figures just stayed up.
- Well, I mean same
with the studio as well.
- Yeah, yours didn't.
- Yeah.
- It's weird 'cause the
figures that had fallen
looked like pretty normal figures
but the one that I really expect to break,
didn't move at all.
- Well, I mean, it's
the same here as well.
Like at the old track station.
- I expected Rohan to just be over.
- All of these knockedover,
but the only casualty we had
was fucking Mike.
- Fucking Mike.
- Every time I'm not at my house
and there's an earthquake in Japan,
I just assume my house
is gonna be demolished
when I'm back.
I'm like, everything's fucked,
I have to rebuild my whole
life, it's all ruined.
- Do you guys have like the
anti-earthquake proof stuff
in your cabinets?
- No.
- You probably should do that.
- It really does make a difference.
- Does it?
- Yeah.
- What is it?
- So basically like,
or, I mean there's lots of
different variations of it.
- Do you need it for most stuff though?
I feel like it's for very specific things.
- We put it on most stuff.
Like most of the big
stuff will sound like,
if you have figuring
cabinets or like bookshelves,
this is like little, kind of like,
they look like little rubber doorstoppers.
- Yeah, I know what they
are, I know what they are.
- And you put them underneath
and it completely stops
the shaking from happening.
- I wanted to get the
figures to stop shaking.
- Yes I have them under
like all of my bookshelves
and figuring cabinets and stuff like that.
And you know, I've seen
the move in an earthquake.
That shit doesn't budge.
So that's really good.
And also like there's also
these little sticky pads
kind of thing that you
can put on some figurines
and stuff like that stops
them from falling over.
- It's just weird that you
have to live in a country
and you can just worry
about like instant death
just happening.
In the UK nothing kills you.
- Instant death, I mean
it;snot exactly instant death
- I was just worried,
well, I mean, it might be.
- If you're in the wrong situation.
- Yeah.
- I suppose we've been lucky enough
to had never have been
in a bad earthquake.
I don't know, I feel like we've never.
- Garnt says this, don't fucking say it.
Well they've been
predicting the mega-quake
for a few years now in Tokyo.
Where there's bound to be some kind of
magnitude eight or nine
fucking earthquake in Tokyo
and I hope to God it happens
in the next three weeks
so I'm not here.
(laughs)
- Jesus Christ.
- I bet you'll wish you were
on the ground floor then, Connor.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Well, I felt like the
shaking was very violent.
I used to live on the 4 to 5th floor
and it used to shake really
weirdly, I didn't like it.
I felt like it was just high enough up
where I got really violent shakes.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I got, I was on the 8th floor,
and I think with the biggest
earthcake we were in,
which was the one where,
- Earthcake.
- Earthcake, earthquake,
(laughs) earthcake.
The biggest earthquake we were in,
which was the one where
my figures fell over,
I was in the toilet at the time, but.
- That's the safest room to be in.
- I was in the bath one time as well.
- But that earthquake just
lasted for so fucking long.
It felt like it lasted like two minutes
or something like that.
- At least, yeah.
- Yeah, go on.
- Yeah, 'cause it just started
and like at which point,
'cause you have to make
this mental judgment of,
at which point do I start giving a shit?
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughs)
Yeah, because most of the
time it's a little shake.
- 'Cause it happens so often.
- It happens so often, so I'm just like,
uh, is this the one I should start caring.
It's not stopping, should
I start caring now?
- But also, what are you
gonna do if you give a shit?
Like, what am I gonna do?
Just be like, oh shit, I'm worried.
- Well, you have to like evacuate
to your nearest evacuation point,
which everyone should know when you move.
Do you know where is it?
- Fuck no.
(laughs)
- You gotta get under
the doorframe, right?
- Doorframe, but also like
if it gets really bad,
then there's like in your local town,
there's usually like evacuation points
that you have to go to.
- That's normally if your
water and shit turns off
and all that, is right?
- No, in a lot of situations
it's like earthquakes
and floods and stuff like that, yeah.
- But why would you leave
your house in an earthquake
if it's like, that's surely
if it's unstable, no?
- Well, I mean, what if.
- The building's unstable.
- It's usually in the case of like,
if the earthquake is really
powerful that your water stops
or your electricity stops, your gas stops.
- That's what I thought, right,
to get supplies and shelter.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause if the winter, if
it's really fucking cold
and your electricity turns off.
- Yeah, then you're kind of screwed it.
- I'm kind of fucked
because I am not stocked up
on any kind of emergency or disaster.
- Yeah, we recently restocked our shit.
So it's all in the front.
- I need to.
I've been meaning to, it's been two years.
- Been meaning to.
- Two years now
I've been meaning to do that.
I'll get around to it.
- Not to wait.
'Cause I remember for
"Journey Across Japan",
we went to like, Sakurajima,
which is that island volcano in Kagoshima.
And I remember two weeks
after we left there,
it fucking erupted. And it's like.
- But high though?
Yeah, it's pretty big as well.
And it made me realize, I was like,
oh yeah, earthquakes are
like the least of my worries
'cause Japan is like
fucking volcanic area.
There's like so many active volcanoes,
like Mount Fuji's a
fucking active volcano.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it is.
- It is, it's an active
volcano and it last erupted,
I think, about 250 years ago.
And they're expecting it to-
- 250 years ago?
- Yeah, in the edo
period, it last erupted.
- Oh!
- And they're expecting it to erupt soon.
- Sick.
- So, I'm like, sick.
(laughs)
- [Navi] They actually did a simulation
if it erupts completely,
it actually reaches all
the way to Hachioji.
- Oh shit.
- [Navi] It's still that fucked.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- It's kinda like Yellowstone,
right, in America?
Where that's like one
of the biggest active,
super volcanoes in the world.
And if that erupts then it's just,
kind of like the end of
civilization for a lot of people.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Makes a lot of the waters
at Yellowstone boiling hot,
like the lakes.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Some horrifying stories of
people jumping in the water,
thinking that they can swim
in it, and it's boiling.
- They just get boiled away.
- Yeah, pretty grim.
- That's pretty grim.
- But I don't know when it's so bad,
when do I leave my house?
I don't know that.
Is there a hard guide on
when to leave your house?
- I mean, I'm pretty sure
you'll know when you'll know.
You know what I mean?
- Like when it gets to
the point where it's like,
oh, I can't be here for
a multitude of reasons,
then it's time to go.
- Yeah, the ones that I
don't really get scared
of the earthquakes in Japan,
but the ones that do kind
of make me uncomfortable
is when it starts small and
it just keeps getting bigger.
And then you're like, when will it stop?
Will it keep escalating?
Because when it starts off big
and it doesn't get any worse,
I'm like, okay cool.
- It's the long ones for me.
- Yeah, where it starts,
it shakes, shakes, shakes!
And you're like, please,
okay please, please stop.
- This is like when is this gonna peak?
Where's the peak, this is the peak?
No, it's not peaking yet.
I just feel like it's the British in me,
where you just don't take
any kind of like natural
disaster seriously.
- I'm just like, come on, pack it in.
All right, stop this now, come on.
I've had enough of this,
I'm finished, come on.
- It's a natural disaster.
Come on, there's no natural
disasters in the world.
- So you guys don't have
any natural disaster?
- No.
- There's some flooding, but very light.
It's not really.
- Right, right.
- We have flooding here.
- I hear of like a
weather warning in Japan.
I'm just like, what the
fuck's a weather warning?
- How can weather kill you?
- My phone has been on
permanent weather warnings
since I've moved here, I'm pretty sure.
I'd love to imagine the
first time a British person
like went abroad, in 1600s
and there's an earthquake,
like what the fuck was that?
What the fuck was that?
And they're like, yeah,
that happens all the time.
What do you mean that
happens all the time?
The Earth just moves?
- Yeah the Earth just moves.
- And you're all okay with this?
You haven't asked
management what's going on?
- It's a living.
- And they're like, yeah, yeah,
and sometimes the mountain explodes.
The mountain explodes?
And fire?
- The mountain explodes,
we get these things called typhoons.
- Yeah, they're like,
what do you mean lava?
That's hell, that's hell coming out.
We've only seen that in the
books, this doesn't happen?
This is nonsense.
- It's 20,000 leagues under the sea.
- And you accept this?
Is this okay with you?
- It's like, what is a typhoon?
It's just a bit of wind aint it?
Bit of wind's never hurt anyone.
It's just a bit of rain,
we get that all the time.
- It's a bit of rain and wind.
- What do you mean nature
destroyed your house,
and did you get a refund?
What is all this?
- What is a Tsunami,
it's just waves, aint it?
Yeah, when we think about it,
Japan really is world
number one when it comes to
the variety of fucking things
that can kill you in nature.
We really do have everything.
- 'Cause I remember before
I moved out of England,
you'd hear about these
disasters that happened
all the way on the
other side of the world.
Like the Japan tsunami,
which was an awful tragedy that happens.
And you just didn't,
it never quite sank in.
- It never felt real.
- Like how bad it was.
Like I remember just
before we moved to Japan
where you guys are having
like super bad typhoons
and like the videos that
came out just look super bad
and I was just like.
It still doesn't sink into me
that it's just this bad here
in Japan, as a British person,
'cause I've just never
experienced it IRL, in real life.
It's never just happened
right in front of me.
- It really is completely different,
you can watch like,
hundreds of videos on it
and the one that you've actually
experienced in real life
is unlike anything you would ever imagine.
It's like those typhoons look bad,
it's a hundred times worse in real life.
- Watching earthquakes
from the 2011 earthquake
is like, really fucking weird.
- It's fucking terrifying, dude.
- Just seeing people just
everything's shaking super badly,
I'm like, oh gosh.
- And just like the water
level rising and shit
is like terrifying.
That happened 10 years ago, man.
- Yeah time flies.
- Yeah, 2011.
- Holy shit, I was still in university.
- I would gladly take
volcanoes if we can get onsens.
Stick a volcano somewhere in
Wales, I will have an onsen.
- Would onsen culture work in the UK?
- If we had volcanoes, yeah.
- You sure?
- Yeah, I think so.
- I wouldn't.
- I agree.
They'd serve alcohol.
- You just want it to work.
- I'll make it work, we'll serve beer.
- Not if people have to get
naked in front of each other.
- I think you underestimate how.
- I think that culture just
wouldn't work in the UK.
- It wouldn't work.
- I think it could work.
- If you teach them from a young age.
Listen, get naked.
Getting naked is normal with your homies.
- You can teach a group
of people cannibalism
from a young age and they'll
think it's all right.
- Yeah, we're not talking about,
like if the entire history
of the UK had changed
to introduce this culture
from the beginning,
'cause then they'd just be
fucking Japan, wouldn't they?
- If you gave them a free
beer at the end of it,
you go in naked with your
boys, you get a free beer,
they'd do it.
- You sure?
- 100%
- I doubt.
If I went up to a guy from the UK,
like born and bred, never
left the country and I said,
I'll give you a beer
if you get in this bath
with this other dude naked.
- When you say it like that,
that sounds way worse 'cause that's.
- So that's what an onsen is.
- 'Cause they're probably imagining
some tight traditional bath
where their dicks are touching
and they're like, oh God,
oh, I'm so scared of penises.
- I mean there are
onsens like that though.
- Yeah, but not really public ones though.
- Oh, well, I mean, we've been in one.
- Have we?
- Yeah, remember.
- Yeah.
- We've been pretty close
together in an onsen.
- Yeah at the end of the cycling tour.
We went in that really,
really tight onsen.
- It was like me, you, Joey and Chris
and our legs were definitely touching.
- Yeah.
- I don't remember this.
(laughs)
- That just shows how used
to it you've gotten, right?
- Yeah, it's just like nothing to you.
- I'm sure someone who's not
used to that type of culture
would find that traumatizing.
- Especially a lot of Brits, you know?
- Imagine being scared of a penis though.
I just couldn't imagine it.
- I mean, you'd be surprised.
Like not even being scared of penises,
but just the social boundary
of seeing your mate's penis
or seeing someone close to you
and just knowing what
they look like naked.
I mean, I'm totally fine with it now,
but that's because I've done it
since I was with you boys right.
- It's that one thing of
just getting to that point
and once you're over
it, then you're over it.
But I think for a lot of people,
it stops at getting to that point.
- Yeah, maybe in the
UK, if it was in the UK,
I would think it's weird.
- Which is why for me, it's such a shame
because when people from overseas
come to Japan for the first
time and they're like,
I wanna know everything
about the culture, you know?
What are some really
unique Japanese things.
And of course the first thing
I think all of his onsens.
But immediately I always
hesitate, being like,
I get this, you're about to see my dick,
but in like a cool way.
- I said cyber punk
music, when you said that.
- In a nice relaxing way.
We're in a bath together
and yes, we're naked,
but it's not weird, it's
not weird, trust me.
And we're with other
random people as well,
but it's not weird, you know.
- The first thing I tell
people now, it's just like,
you wanna come to Japan?
You want me to take you around?
We'll go into an onsen right?
Just get that out of the way.
- I think if someone's willing
to go to the onsen with you.
- They probably will be
up for anything, right?
- Yeah everything Japanese culture.
I feel like if you can't put
your own cultural differences
aside to participate in another culture,
then I don't think you're.
- I agree.
- And yeah, again,
that's what I kind of use
as a gauge of like cultural
understanding for that person.
It's like, if they can get over this,
then you'll be fine in Japan.
- I'm very open to some things,
but there are some things
where I've seen in like,
you know when they had, what was it?
Was it a TV show called "Tribe" in the UK.
It's dude who went around tribes
in the Amazon or something.
And there was one thing
that he did that I was like,
"Okay, I don't think I'd that,"
and it was like a penis
inverting ceremony or something.
- Oh that!
- Oh that one!
- Did you see the video
where the guy faints
when they do it to him?
I was like, yeah, you know what,
I thought I was up for a lot
but I think that's where I'm good.
- Have you seen the one where
they have to wear that glove
of just like bullet ants?
- Yeah, oh my God.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- And I'm just like, why
would anyone wanna do this?
- If I was, you gave me enough beers,
maybe I do the ants thing but.
- Let's go!
- But it's the video of that guy,
the tribal chief does it to him
and he just faints immediately.
Oh God, it sounded terrible.
- Yeah, I think there
are many penises going,
ah, just listening to you, right?
Just like, aah!
- Yeah, I'm pretty much up for anything
that doesn't involve destroying my body
or pain or stuff like that.
I'm pretty much down for anything.
- Yeah, I'm usually down for
anything when it comes to like,
especially when it comes to
things like food and drinks.
- Yeah, which is why I hate
it when people lie to me
about their, they make a joke that like,
yeah, our culture, we do this
and then they just lie to me.
I didn't have to put
my penis out in public.
I'm kidding.
But this is why I trust my
friends when I go somewhere new
and they're like, this is what we do here.
I'm like, I trust you, that sounds weird,
but I trust you, please don't fuck me.
Like Garnt could be like,
yeah, so in Thailand we get
our dicks out in restaurants
and swing them around and be like,
all right, well, okay.
- This is the culture.
- When in Rome, do as the Romans.
I would trust Garnt if Garnt
told something like that.
Garnt was like, yeah, you
have to spit on the food
before you eat it.
- I'm just waiting for
the perfect opportunity
to abuse that power.
- He's gonna do it, he's
gonna fucking do it,
I know he is as well,
that's the worst part.
- I'm just waiting for
the perfect opportunity
to abuse that power.
- And I'm gonna do it.
- 'Cause I've only got one chance to do it
before I completely lose that trust.
- It's like Joey in
Australia, he'll be like,
yeah, you have to snort all your alcohol
and I'll be like, oh okay.
- You have to drink
alcohol through your eye.
- I think a few Australians do do that.
- Yeah, we do do that.
- It's called a suicide
shot I'm pretty sure.
- To be fair we used to have
a lot of shows in the UK
that would cover binge
drinking and clubbing.
I don't know why we had
TV shows about this.
And there'd be this one show
and this is where I first discovered
that people did vodka shots
through their eyeball.
- Yeah, yeah.
And it was weird and they would
do it and they'd ask them,
the interviewer would ask
them, why did you do it?
He's like, 'cause I
just get drunk so fast.
And I'm like, is drinking not fast enough?
It's pretty fast, it's
pretty damn instant.
It's pretty fucking fast.
And then it just immediately
cut to a doctor who was like,
yeah well actually, you know,
inserting any kind of alcohol in your eye
is extremely dangerous and
can remove the lipid layer
of an eye and can permanently
damage and possibly blind you.
- Yeah, of course.
- And I was like, oh.
- I don't need a professional
doctor telling me that.
Like it should be common sense.
- Yeah it's like a splinter in your butt.
It's like, I didn't
need a doctor to tell me
that that didn't need to go there.
It's weird, man.
It's so strange 'cause
I feel like in the UK
with partying and all that,
there's so many stuff that you just do it
'cause everyone else tells you to do it.
And I would just always
sat there thinking like
what the fuck is going on.
- Yeah, it's definitely,
especially in a university where-
- Oh my God.
- Just the idea of doing a dirty shot now
just makes me feel sick.
- What is a dirty shot?
Explain to the viewers Garnt,
and me, 'cause I forgot.
- Yeah, I don't know what it is either.
- Or I dirty pint.
You just, you play
probably most of the time
it's fucking ring of fire,
which is the university game.
And then you have this pint
glass in the middle where,
whenever you draw certain cards,
you have to fill up with whatever alcohol.
- I feel sick hearing that.
- Whatever alcohol that
person is drinking.
- Yeah.
- And sometimes if you're in
like an ultra hardcore party,
then you fill up with like other shit
that you would never
put in a fucking drink.
Shit like washing up
liquid or stuff like that.
- Yeah, they would do it.
- Or Tabasco sauce.
Or Nandos sauce.
- We had a rule in ours
where whoever lost,
they had to leave the room for 30 seconds.
And anything in the kitchen
could be put in the drink.
- Yeah.
- People would put like pepper
grains, washing up liquid
and they would drink it.
- I understand pepper grains and Tabasco,
but washing up liquid?
- You'd immediately throw it
up, there's no way you could
- Yeah. I've actually done
it before, when I was 17.
- You fucking idiot.
- Yeah you're a fucking ass.
- I'm lucky, for some
reason during my whole time
at university when I played
this game, I never got it.
But I would've refused.
- I mean, we played that game,
but we made it stuff that
you could actually drink.
- Yeah it's really disgusting.
- That's the civilized thing to do.
- I had food poisoning
yesterday and I feel dreadful
and hearing this makes you
feel even more dreadful.
- Why did you get food poisoning Conor?
- I ate a bad sausage.
- You had a bad sausage.
- I ordered two sausages, I cut one up
and it was very, very pink on the inside.
- That's a bad sign.
- And I thought no, I'm
not eating that one.
But I cut up the other
one and it looked okay.
- And you ate it,
and it was not.
- What kinda sausage was it?
- Was it Italian sausage?
- A fucking terrible sausage.
- Narrator, and it was not okay.
- I feel sick describing it.
- You have Connoren food poisoning.
- Yeah, you are so susceptible to it.
I think since you've been in Japan,
you've had food poisoning
at least three or four times
from my memory.
- Three times.
- What's the worst food
poisoning you've ever had?
- The () one?
- () one?
- Yeah, that was the worst one.
- You had food poisoning for a week.
- I was shitting and
vomiting for a week straight
It was terrible.
God it was so bad.
- I think I've only had
food poisoning once.
- In Japan, 'cause they
should have so much raw shit.
- Yeah.
- Like you know, they serve
raw chicken here, you know?
And they say like, ah,
there's no salmonella.
There is salmonella, there's
just way less of it right?
- You're just less likely to get it.
It doesn't mean you can't get it.
- I'm not being funny, but you
should not eat raw chicken.
Like I don't care if Japan
is like, yeah, it's safe.
No.
- I've had it before.
- Yeah, but it's not.
- It's not even that good.
- It's not that good and
you all rolling a dice.
- Yeah.
- You can eat it, but
you are rolling a dice.
- Well, I had raw chicken at an Izakaya
that specialized in raw chicken.
'Cause there's a lot of Izakayas
that just like give it to you.
- I still wouldn't.
- It's a cultural thing, right?
Where people would just like,
this is safe, this is safe.
And I'm just like, is it though, is it?
Is it safe?
- It's like you are eating
it and there is a risk,
there is still a risk.
- Of course there's a risk.
- But you are unlikely
to get food poisoning
from eating the raw chicken,
but there was still a
chance you can get it.
- Yeah, you can still get it,
especially if your stomach's
not used to it.
- Way more than other foods.
- But, I mean, a lot of things,
especially I feel like in
Asia, which just has a lot of,
a lot less standards when it comes to say
the health and safety
of the food you serve.
I feel like even like Japan
compared to the rest of Asia
has really, really good food standards,
compared to fucking Southeast Asia.
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh my God.
- But Japan compared to the UK
is like Japan doesn't bat
an eye if it's like pinkish
and I'm like, oof, my
chicken's pink in the middle.
I'm like, oh God, don't
know if I can eat that.
- I mean yeah, the only
time I got food poisoning
was when I went to the
Philippines for the first time.
And of all things I could
have got food poisoning from,
it wasn't the duck fetus,
it wasn't even the water,
it was a fucking mango shake.
I ate a fucking mango
straight off the fucking street vendor,
and that's what gave me food poisoning.
I'm like cool, amazing.
It was a fantastic shake,
but man, I was shitting,
I was pissing out my
ass for about two days.
It was horrible.
- Yeah, I think the worst
food poisoning I've ever got
was from China actually when
I was still living there.
And you know, when you live in China like,
the food there is fucking great,
especially the street food,
but it's just trying to pinpoint
where you got food
poisoning there is like.
- A needle in a haystack.
- It's kinda like a needle in a haystack.
You're just like, where did,
which one of these food stands
did I get food poisoning from,
it could be any one of them.
- Could be like a culmination
of all of them too,
just come together as one.
- I remember it was so bad
that I almost had to go to the hospital
because I remember it was new year's Eve
for one of the years, I
can't remember which year,
exact year it was.
But I remember I was sitting on the toilet
and I needed to throw up
at the same time that I was shitting.
(laugh)
- Those are the worst.
- You laugh but it was a
traumatic experience for me.
- What were you just alternating?
- I was trying.
- Or did you have to like.
- I was trying to keep
it in, but that one time,
one time I literally could
not like hold either one.
So I literally didn't like needed to like,
I was sitting on the toilet
and I needed to like try to like aim.
- I can't listen to this.
- It's awful, I don't
wanna get too graphic.
- I've done that before.
- But it was the most awful
food poisoning experience
I've ever had.
It's kind of like a scene
out of "South Park" where.
- I know which one you're.
- Where he literally
shits and then pukes up
and then has a nose
bleed at the same time.
That was my experience.
- Yeah, say what you will
about fast food chains.
I've never gotten food poisoning
from a fast food chain.
- I've never gotten food poisoning,
you mean like junk food
and stuff like that?
- Yeah like McDonald's whatever.
I've never gotten.
- I've never gotten
food poisoning from it personally,
but I have gotten very sick.
- I felt bad, but I've
never had to throw up
after eating like KFC or something.
I don't know about America,
I've seen some really
ghastly ones in America.
But in the UK and Japan
I've had nothing but good experiences.
- No, Japan is really good with fast food.
I think like the few times
that I've had McDonald's
in America, I was like,
I really wanna throw up.
- I feel so rough.
- I really wanna throw this
up, yeah, it's horrible.
- I don't know how they
make burgers tastes so bad
at McDonald's in America.
I don't know what they do.
- I dunno, man.
- It's 'cause McDonald's just
makes enough money worldwide
and in America there's just
so much better burgers right,
that it doesn't matter.
- There's more higher-end
burgers in America.
- There's way more competition
in America, I feel.
I feel like in America,
McDonald's lives off the
reputation of how would.
- It's the American burger.
- The rest of the world, right?
This episode is sponsored by Bokksu.
- Bokksu is a monthly snack
box subscription service
that delivers original assortments
of premium Japanese
snacks and tea pairings.
Bokksu's not just a premium
snack subscription service,
but a way of getting to
know the Japanese culture.
- First time Bokksu customers will receive
the Season Of Japan box
so they can get a taste
of the snacks per season, and
shipping to the U.S. is free.
- Get outta here.
- It's almost autumn here in Japan.
And you know what that means boys?
- What does it mean?
- The Autumn Box is here.
- No!
- That's right, it's
right here, looking at it.
- Are you talking about fall?
- Fall.
- Right, Americans?
- In Japan, people love to observe
the changing of the leaves by
going on an autumn leaf hunt
and snacking on manju.
They also attend Aki Matsuri
or the fall festivals
to commemorate a great harvest.
- Ooh.
- What have we got in there Connor?
- We have some milk manju,
where is that gamers?
Manju's a historic steamed Japanese sweet
created by wrapping
ingredients like bean paste
in a kneaded wheat shell.
This treat is milk flavored for a creamy
and sweet tasting experience.
- Delicious.
- And we also have kyoto
matcha waffle sandwiches,
crunchy and matcha flavored,
an amazing collaboration of experiences.
- This actually looks really good.
- That actually looks pretty good.
And more!
- Oh Connor, I think you forgot about
the setouchi heart-shaped
lemon mini pies as well.
- Oh my God, is that those over there?
- It is right here.
- Look how cute those are,
those heart-shaped pies.
- Adorable.
- Look at these.
- And there's tons more in the box,
this box is stacked gentlemen.
And you can get all of
these lovely snacks and more
for Halloween with the code Trashtaste10.
Link is in the description
to get 10% off your Bokksu subscription.
- Thank you Bokksu for
sponsoring us today,
back to the episode.
Speaking of traveling and stuff,
this is the last podcast
before we head back to the UK,
me and you, so you're
not going to see a break,
but we're going to have
about like a six, seven week?
- Yeah, like a month and
a half break, basically.
Yeah, a six week break.
- Which is the longest break
we've ever taken from Trash Taste.
- I wanna see people who are
like bingeing Trash Taste.
Like watching this episode
and then going to the next
and being like, what the fuck happened?
- I wonder if there's any difference?
Like what if I just get a scar,
like a really cool scar?
- You just come back and you're
just like completely bald.
Just got an eye patch on
or something like that.
Woohaa!
- It's been really with
me for the past few weeks
because I've been living alone, I guess,
for like the past two, three weeks?
- Oh yeah, 'cause Sydney
went back to America?
- Yeah, Sydney, she's back in America.
I think this is like the
longest we've been apart.
- First time, huh?
(laughs)
- And it's so weird not
having a partner home.
And it's just one, the
home feels so empty.
Like my God, like if it
wasn't for Corona lockdown,
I would want to meet so many
people 'cause I'm just like,
I need to do something to remind me.
- You need someone to talk to.
- I need someone to talk to
and I need someone to fill in the gap
of having no one in your house.
I've forgotten what that felt like, right?
- I feel that, I feel that.
- It's just 'cause
you're used to it right?
To me, it's like, I don't feel that way.
- Yeah, I now see why you try to meet up
with as many people as you can.
'Cause if I was in your
shoes I would do the same
'cause it's lonely without having someone
just there to talk to
whenever you want to.
- I also just really like
being alone sometimes.
I really value being able to
just like do whatever I want.
- No, I like my alone time too.
- No, but like.
- But only to a certain extent.
- I like it a lot, a lot.
- I like my alone time as well
and I feel like any healthy relationship,
you have space to have your alone time.
But if you're feeling lonely,
there's just someone there.
Also, not a thing is
that the chores are now,
like I'm in charge of all the chores,
and I'm just like, what is this?
Like, this is gonna
sound a bit misogynistic.
But like in my household, I'm
in charge of the washing up,
and Sydney is in charge
of the laundry, right?
And so I was just used
to only do the washing up
and having the woman
doing the laundry, right?
- Why did you have to say it like that?
- I just wanted it to sound
as misogynist as I can.
because now I am, there's
no one to do the laundry
and I'm just like, woman,
where is my laundry done!
And I just realized, I
have to do it myself now.
- I just like to imagine I just
slowly enter Garnt's house,
and from across the house, I just hear,
"Woman, I need a fresh pair of underwear!"
- You really got done dirty
'cause laundry is like the
easiest of the household tasks.
- Yeah, I'm the one that does
the laundry in our house.
- I think washing up the
dishes is far more painful.
- Oh, I hate washing up the dishes.
- Why did you agree to that?
- Because I also hate
doing the laundry as well.
- No I like the laundry.
- Why?
- Laundry's nice bro.
Fresh sheets.
- I mean, now that we've
bought a washing machine
with a built-in dryer.
All I have to do is just fucking
take it out and fold it up.
But I liked the process
of folding up washing,
I don't know why I hate that.
- It's meditative.
- It's so unoptimized.
Because the thing is, the
thing about the laundry
is that at least with washing up,
it's just a one activity
thing, you get it over
with laundry, you have to put it in
and then you have to remember
that you put the laundry in
and sometimes I'm such
a forgetful little shit,
that like you forget hours
afterwards that you had laundry
in the laundry machine
and then you take it out
and it fucking stinks
because you left it in there for so long.
So then you have to re-laundry
your fucking laundry!
- Well that just sounds
like a you problem.
- That is a me problem,
gonna hate laundry.
- The laundry machines often have this
very loud thing called a beeping noise?
- Yeah, it goes, (beeps) when it's done.
- Yeah, but sometimes you just.
- You might have heard
it on your microwave,
kinda same thing.
- Sometimes you're just doing shit,
sometimes you're just like,
oh, let me just finish
up this piece of work
and then I'll do the laundry
and then you just forget
that you hear that.
- It sounds like a you problem,
'cause if I'm doing work
and then I hear from my
laundry machine going (beeps),
I'm like, all right
time to do the laundry.
I don't know how hard it is.
- Really not that difficult.
Also, I don't have to
worry about dishes anymore
because we have a dishwasher.
- I wish, I wish, I wish that was me.
- I feel like I'm like a
cave man just evolving.
- I feel like discovering
civilization for the first time.
- Yeah, I mean dishes I was used to doing,
but with laundry, is this
how men felt in the '60s?
(laughs)
- We're gonna get
canceled for this episode.
- I'm not saying shit bro.
- Garnt's gonna cancel this episode.
I disagree with all of
Garnt's opinions here.
- Because in our house
I have to do the laundry and the dishes
because that's the one
chore that Arki hates doing.
So she does like the vacuuming
and like the cleaning
up and stuff like that
because I fucking hate
vacuuming the house.
- I also hate vacuuming the house.
- Imagine doing all of it yourself.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Well, I had to do that
when I was living on my own.
- That's crazy.
- But now I feel bad 'cause my two chores,
which is the laundry and the dishes,
I just let the machine do it.
So I literally just press
a button, I'm like, done.
And it's great.
- I wish that was me.
I have to wash my dishes by hand
and my laundry doesn't
have a dryer as well.
- Dude, I'm telling you, man, when you.
- I don't really like the
dryers in laundry machines,
I feel like they ruin the clothes.
- I don't like the dryer either.
- Really?
- But I also hate having to
put out the laundry to dry.
- Yeah, I hate having to
put up the laundry more.
- There's something good
about an old-fashioned,
natural dryer that just
kind of gets to me.
- It does, it does.
But the problem with that,
is that you are at the
mercy of the weather right?
- Yeah.
- Because what are you meant
to do in the winter time.
- Hang it inside, right?
- The best, the best.
- Why, just hang it outside,
what are you talking about?
- What, in the rain?
- It's not permanently
raining in the winter.
- Yeah but what if you have
laundry that just finished
and it starts raining.
- Yeah, it's unfortunate
but you can just hang
it up somewhere else.
- Yeah, inside.
So basically what I just fucking said!
- You can do it outside,
it's not a big deal.
- No it is a big deal 'cause
it's gonna get dirty again
from the rain.
- You wash it against,
it's even more clean.
- See that's what someone
living on their own would say.
- Yeah, I know, right?
- I would've said the same
thing if I was living alone
because it's like, oh, it's my
clothes, fuck it, who cares?
But I have to take care of
another person's clothes
and she doesn't quite like that.
- Does Aki get like, no,
you have to do it this way.
- Well, no, it's not so
much Aki's preference,
it's more so just fucking common sense.
Don't try and dry washing in the rain.
- Don't you put it out when it's raining.
Sometimes you put it out,
then it starts raining,
you forget that it's raining,
'cause you didn't notice right away,
and it's a little wet,
fuck I have to do it again.
- At that point that's
just annoying right?
'Cause then you just take,
I feel like leaving it out in
the rain, I have to rewash it.
Because that washes out the
good stuff about the laundry.
- I'm simply one man, I
cannot conquer nature.
I've accepted that.
- Right, so that's why I
bought a washing machine
that has a really good
dryer attached to it.
- You're trying to play God.
- No, no, no, no, no, no,
because here's the thing, right?
Here's the thing.
Because if you dry your
clothes in the dryer,
then you're gonna need to
iron your shirts, right?
- Yeah.
- I feel if it's like naturally dried,
sometimes if you get it out
just fresh out of the washing,
you like, what's?
- Whip it?
- Whip it.
I was trying to think of the English word
'cause I just knew the Thai word for it.
You fucking whip the clothes
and it dries naturally,
you just get the creases out.
And it's like a nice.
- Sometimes.
- A lot of the time, unless you're wearing
a really expensive shirt
or something that needs to be ironed.
Most of the time for
like a natural t-shirt
you get the creases out.
So that's why I've always hated actually
having to use the dryer.
- Well, I get that, but there's also like,
we use like these kind of drying sheets
that you throw into the washing
machine after it's done,
that creates less creases in the clothes.
It's like a thing,
apparently, I didn't know.
Aki found on Amazon and I was like.
- But pants are sort
of bullshit like this,
that sometimes works,
sometimes it doesn't.
- Yeah, true.
- It sounds like yeah,
put this in your fridge
and it'll make it smell like oranges.
And then it like smells like oranges.
- Like my last washing machine supposedly
had a dryer inside of it and
I span it for like three hours
and I was like, oh cool,
it's just a little less
damp than was before.
- Japan's the king at selling you shit
that you think you need,
that you don't actually need
and it doesn't work.
- I just remember, so do
you guys have an issue
of like, your fucking trash
really, really stinking in the summer.
- Yeah.
- Like no, I remember
when I go to your house,
your trash, for some reason,
always smells dreadful.
- I'd don't know why.
- My trash doesn't smell that bad.
- Like, the burner balls sometimes.
'Cause like we don't cook often right?
So sometimes it's just, we
have like a little trash there,
but especially in the summer,
sometimes it's just fucking
decomposes in the summer.
- How fucking long are you
leaving the this there for?
- Do you not throw it out every week?
- Uh, no.
- Well, there's your problem.
- Why are you not throwing
it out every week?
- Because it doesn't get full every week.
- It doesn't matter,
you should throw it out.
- How do you, as a couple,
not get it full every week.
I get it for every week on my own.
- You're burnables?
- Yeah, every week.
- Yeah, I get ours full every week, man.
We sometimes have to go through two bags,
we have to go through two
bags of burnables a week.
- Like I dunno, we finish our foods.
- I finished my food too, what
are you trying to say Garnt?
- Then how are you filling, what are you,
what is it filled with?
- Sometimes Amazon comes in
the box, it's burnable stuff.
- But that's cardboard?
- No, no, no, no, like
sometimes they give material,
that's not the polystyrene
and it's not bubble wrap.
It's like the shit that's burnable.
- Yeah, and then if you for example,
if you get Uber Eats, for example, right?
- I get a lot of Uber Eats.
Yeah like the boxes and stuff like that,
the food scraps, that's all burnable.
- I feel very excited.
- You wash the boxes?
- Do you not wash the boxes?
- Depends on the box,
what type of material.
- I do not wash the box.
I just throw it all in the burnables.
- Wow, wow Joey!
- Wait, so why does yours stink then?
- Yeah, why is your stinking worse?
- Because I don't push
the box in the burnables.
The burnables is purely just food waste.
- Well, that's why it stinks.
- Well, of course!
- Where are you putting
the other burnables?
- Yeah, where are you putting the boxes.
- What other burnables are there?
- A lot of the food trays.
- Like food scraps.
- And they'll say if you
have like certain materials,
if it gets oily or if it
gets stuff on it, it's, yeah.
- Wait, wait, so when you order a pizza,
do you wash the pizza box when it's done?
- Like, it goes on with the cardboard.
- No, no!
- Your supposed to put
in the burnables dude.
- Yes, that's grease,
there's grease in it.
- No because most of the time,
if it comes in like a plastic
tray or plastic whatever,
you can just wash it and
then put it in the plastics.
- Plastics yeah.
But a lot of the food
trays aren't plastic.
- They're cardboard like, paper.
- No?
- Like styrofoam stuff.
- Most of it is plastic.
Most of everything I get is plastic.
- Most of the stuff I get is styrofoam.
- So, what happens
right is, unfortunately,
most of my burnables like
pretty much 90% of my burnables
is pure food waste.
- Yeah.
- And that just, we don't
have a lot of food waste.
So it just ends up that a
lot of food just accumulates.
Not a lot of food, a little
bit of food accumulates there
and because it's in the summer,
it just decomposes so quickly.
- Well, that's all the more reason
to take it out every week,
even if it's not full.
- I have a small bag that's
attached to the kitchen counter
because I go through so much tea
and tea decomposes very fast.
- Yeah.
- That's where all the tea
and all the small bits of food
that I don't eat goes.
So it's a tiny plastic bag
that I can tie up and take out every week
if I want to, and it doesn't smell.
- I think it's not actually just the food
it's just 'cause it's so
humid as well that just like.
- You should definitely get
the thing out of the house.
- Like the humidity
condenses inside the bag
so it ends up that you
have like the garbage water
at the bottom as well.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You can throw out tiny bags,
you know, that's allowed.
It doesn't have to be big bags of trash.
You can throw out little.
- You can throw out little bit
konbini bag levels of trash.
- Sometimes you just forget.
- Again, that sounds
like a you problem, bro.
- This feels like consulting
people on their recycling.
- No, I mean, what I was going to say was,
so obviously the trash ended
up smelling at least like,
sometimes we throw it out
every week in the summer,
but it's sometimes still just smelled.
- I really only get smelly
trash when I open the trash.
- In my case, if I open up the trash
and it really stinks like
that decomposing smell,
I just double bag it.
So I close up the first bag,
and I get a second bag
and I wrap that up again.
And then boom, there you
go, the smell's gone.
- Yeah, because what we did was we,
there was this device from a Daiso, right?
I think it's Daiso, or like Amazon.
- Already red flags.
- There was this device from Daiso.
- Stink be gone.
- That was basically like,
you know that thing you put on the toilet
to make it smell nice whenever you flush.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It was like the equivalent of that,
but you put it on the bottom
of the lid of the garbage can
and completely solved the issue.
Our bins smelled great, it smelled fresh.
- Japan is the only country
on Earth that gives a shit
what the shit smells like.
- It smelled fresh and I was like, great,
this is a fucking amazing device.
Oh my God, this has just saved me,
this has made my kitchen
actually pleasant to be in.
Until about a month in,
when we needed to take out the trash.
And we noticed that there
were a lot of flies.
Like I don't know how the flies,
where the flies came from.
- You never know where
the flies come from.
- I didn't know where the flies came from.
- Oh, yeah you had a lot
of flies, I remember this.
- And I was like, where are
these flies coming from?
And why are they gathering
all around the bin?
'Cause this never happened before, right?
And so Sydney opens the
lid, and there's like a few,
we could see literally like
a few fly eggs on the lid,
on the lid cover.
And I was like, what the
fuck, how did this get here?
And then, and then I had to
wash it, right, obviously.
'Cause Sydney was scared
of it, so I had to wash it.
And then I was like, okay,
I gotta take off the nice smelling thing.
Take it off and, okay
it's like a rectangle,
it's like a rectangle patch,
and I took off the rectangle patch
and the entire patch was filled with eggs.
I had like an entire patch of fly eggs
that were just covered
because of this one patch.
So this nice-smelling
patch had just attracted
all the fucking flies in the vicinity.
- Why?
- I have no idea!
I have no fucking idea.
- Damn, you gotta do
something about that shit bro.
- I had to quarantine the place, my God.
Like the thing, the thing was like.
- I would throw the
trashcan out, just gone.
- The thing was like fucking Chernobyl.
- Like I have to like
quarantine the entire kitchen.
- Hazmat on.
- That is so disgusting.
- Dude, I dunno what it is,
it doesn't matter if you have like
the cleanest kitchen in the world.
I don't know where the fuck
these flies are coming from,
they're just like, it's like
the kitchen is a respawn point
for some of these fucking flies.
Like they just appear out of thin air.
It's like, I am here
now, time to terrorize.
- Yeah, this is like, you know
in like a Junji Ito Manga,
where you turn the panel and
you see like the monster?
That was there when I shredded off
that fucking patch.
- Ah, I feel shit,
shut the fuck up, stop,
you're gonna make me throw up please.
- It's like a page-turn jump scare.
(laughs)
It's like, ah!
- To talk about something
more pleasant, though.
Going back to laundry.
- Yeah.
- Like I remember when I moved out.
- Opened up my laundry
and there was flies?
- I remember moving out of my mom's place,
I was just like laundry.
All you need to put is a
bit of detergent there,
and laundry is done.
My God, I didn't know how
fucking OP fabric softener was
until I started doing my laundry.
Like not many people talk about it,
but my God, fabric softener is one of the,
is a life hack that actually works.
- I literally do like the two
shots of vodka meme with my.
- Two shots of fabric softener.
- Honestly, I go through
detergent so slowly.
- It's like one cup of Vodka.
And it's like the whole
fucking jug I put in.
I know it's bad for your clothes,
but I don't give a shit, it's so comfy.
- I put a tiny amount in and it works.
- 'Cause I feel like with clothes,
and especially with your bed covers,
I don't know how people sleep
without not putting fabric
softener on their bed covers
and bed sheets and stuff.
- Yeah, sure, I wanna be in
that maximum comfort man.
- Damn.
- I wanna be embraced.
- Embraced.
It's like a light hug from your mom.
- You don't wanna sleep naked.
- Exactly.
- I want my nut sack to
feel the fabric softener.
- I want my nut sacks to be embraced.
- I want them to be cradled by my sheets.
Bathed in the God's liquid
known as fabric softener.
I can't wait.
It's gonna be weird though,
It's gonna be weird coming back.
- Yeah.
Are you guys excited?
- Yeah, of course.
Not excited for all the
quarantining we have to do.
- Oh shit, I mean, it's been what,
like a full almost two years now
since you guys were in the UK last?
- Yeah, I haven't seen anyone.
It's weird.
It's weird, I've never gone two years
without seeing my family.
Yeah, it is a massive pain in
the ass to travel right now.
- Yeah, just seeing all the paperwork
you guys have to do to get through.
- Ah, fuck man, Jesus Christ.
- Like getting gout the country
seems pretty simple and easy.
It's getting back in the country that is,
that sounds we're gonna
save our experiences
for when we actually come back.
From third hand experiences,
it actually sounds like a prison camp.
Like I'm not joking.
Like my mate who went out, went back in,
like the experience he told me,
it's not like a prison camp,
but then he sent me an article
of some of the Olympic athletes
that had to come in the
country and had to quarantine.
And they literally also
said that prison camps
will probably, they would
probably would probably
be better treated in prison camps
than they were in like
the quarantine hotels
that they were in.
- Yikes.
- Well, I'm gonna read a lot of manga.
- Yeah, just stock up
on all the manga man.
Like, dude, you can finally
catch up with "One Piece".
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] While you're in quarantine.
Just read "One Piece", man.
Yeah, do it.
- Hope I don't gain too much weight.
'Cause God knows, I'm
just gonna eat and drink
all the time when I'm back.
- Yeah, I know.
- You should like weigh yourself before
just as an experiment.
- I don't wanna know.
I don't wanna know.
- You should.
I wanna know.
- Fuck.
- It's gonna be like Christmas
holidays all over again.
- Exactly.
- Christmas holidays.
I don't know like, do you guys gain weight
during the Christmas holidays?
- Of course, yeah.
- I gain weight generally.
I breathe near McDonald's
and I gain weight.
- Yeah, but hopefully you
guys make it back all right.
I mean, I'm sure it'll be all right.
- Hope so.
- Yeah, I hope so.
- The first thing I'm gonna
do is go to a fucking Nando's.
I'm not even joking.
Like before I hug my
mum, before I say hello,
before I see the family,
get myself to a Nando's.
- It's like, mom, hold
on, hold on for a second.
- I'm gonna go to Greg's and
get a vegan sausage roll.
- Vegan.
- And a Tesco meal
deal, perhaps two maybe.
- Oh, wow, spoiling yourself.
- Because I can.
- 'Cause I'm an adult.
- Don't want a normal portion size?
No, don't think I will.
I think I'll get whatever the fuck I want.
- And then I'll cry because
I'll cry when I've realized
that there's no good food
options where I live.
- I think I'm gonna miss Japan a lot more
than I think I will.
- I think so.
- Like you guys, yeah, I
reckon you guys will obviously
you know, have that like great
rush of, yeah, I'm back home,
I'm seeing my family, I'm seeing my mates.
But then you'll realize,
man, there's just so much shit to do
in Japan I can't do here.
- Yeah, I am looking forward
to ordering a coffee in
English, that's very exciting.
Very exciting times.
- I am like looking forward
to going to a Tesco's,
which is our konbinis and
also doing that in English
and having the clerk respond to me.
- Having an English conversation
with another person.
- Like being asked if I want a
plastic bag and not a fukuro.
That'd be nice. That'd be nice.
- Yeah, they'd be like, do
you want a bag with that?
(speaks in Japanese)
Ah sorry, sorry fuck, nah, I'm good.
- (speaks in Japanese)
- I gotta realize I haven't
paid with my card in so long.
In the UK you just tap it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I'm excited for that.
- Oh yeah, that's a thing!
- You just tap.
- Tap and go.
- Well, I actually can't
do that straight away
because all my cards have expired.
All my UK cards have expired, so yeah,
I'm lucky to have a bit of UK cash on me.
'Cause I've only got my
Japanese card on me right now,
but it's not either Visa or MasterCard,
which is the two companies
that everyone else uses.
It's like JCB or something like that,
which I've only ever heard in Japan.
- Yeah, that's only in Japan.
- And I don't think
anywhere else except it.
- Japan Credit Bureau.
- Is it? I thought it
was Japan Central Bank?
- I thought it was Japan credit Bureau.
- I don't know, it's Japan something
so it doesn't work outside Japan.
- It's all nonsense.
Well, hopefully, I mean,
luckily I guess the good thing
is that, yeah, since it will be six weeks
we're gonna have a lot to
talk about next episode.
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
- Hopefully, you'll know if
things have gone smoothly
if Trash Taste is uninterrupted.
- Yeah, exactly.
- If one of us get stuck or for
some reason RIP Trash taste.
- How's it gonna feel for you Joey?
Not being in, not having
Trash Taste record every week?
- I mean, September is just gonna be
a very slow months for me.
It's gonna be weird waking
up on a Tuesday morning
being like, wait, I don't
have to go to the office.
It's not a work day today, what the fuck?
Yeah, but I think for me,
'cause I'm not gonna go back to Australia
'cause I don't wanna go
through that whole process,
but I'm gonna go see my family in Japan,
who I haven't seen in two years.
So that's gonna be nice to
finally catch up with them.
'Cause they're all a vaccine now.
- Fuck yeah.
- So, yeah, it's gonna be nice to just
live how I used to live three years ago
when everything was a lot more simple.
- I'm waiting for the day until
they actually let tourists in here.
- Oh dude.
- Yeah, I think that's
why I wanna go back now,
'cause I'm like I don't see
it happening any time soon.
If I go now, I'm fine if
it takes another two years.
- Yeah definitely.
- You think it's gonna take two years?
- No, but if it does, it does.
- It could.
- I don't know how long it's gonna take.
- Yeah, but uh,
- But anyway, I guess
we'll wrap it up there.
- We'll wrap it up here.
Hey, look at all these patreons
though, they're pretty cool.
- Ooh, look at them
- Thank you, thank you.
- Amazing patrons, hey guys,
if you wanna support us
on Patreon and support the show,
then make sure to go to patreon
on patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also, follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
But yeah, guys, have a good.
- I feel gross now, after
hearing that fly story.
Sorry, I just feel disgusting,
and I feel sick too.
I'm surprised I made it for this episode.
- I feel gross just having to say it.
I literally think back and I'm just,
I needed to tell someone
because I'm still scarred.
It was like a fucking
horror story, it sucked.
- Free story for you man.
- I interrupted you Joey, again.
- No, no I was just gonna say
I hope you guys have a good trip.
- I hope so too.
- And see you guys in six weeks
and we'll see you guys next week.
- Next week.
- Nothing has changed.
- Like nothing has changed!
- If we did our job right
and we get back okay.
- And we are in the country okay.
I know problems happens,
which are touch wood.
Fucking slam that wood.
- Fucking slam wood.
Al lright guys have a good one.
- [All] Bye!
(calm music)